time
[Music]
13. o'clock
[Music]
hey everybody what's going on it's
Wednesday yep time once again for the
show yeah it's gonna be a more of a fun
show video nasties will return into
video nasties yeah we did do a show
about this like a long time ago yeah
because you were banned in England yeah
yeah like kind of some of them were
banned it's like kind of complicated but
I guess like some of them were banned
and then some of them were just I don't
know there was like this whole like
legal thing about it it's I feel like
it's mostly pass now because they do
still have
I mean they still have a thing where
it's like the equivalent of the American
MPAA right where you know they see a
film and they're like well they decide
what they're going to rate it and they
said oh well we would rate it for
example in the US it'd be like we're
gonna rate it nc17 unless you cut out
this that and the other and then it'll
be an R so it's kind of the same kind of
thing but yeah there was uh kind of
starting I guess the late 70s early 80s
there was a massive massive moral panic
in the UK about these exploitation films
mostly horror films uh you know and how
they were gonna cause the downfall of
civilization well that's what usually
happens
I need some [ __ ] movies man [ __ ]
civilization will fall
he said the sound is very low I wonder
why I haven't changed anything
I haven't changed anything
so I don't really know why it would be
but yeah everybody's saying it well not
one person is saying it no just one
person maybe that's just you it might
just be just you dude I mean I didn't I
didn't touch anything so that's I don't
really know let me see uh
here
on my device grandther said uh snake
pliskin is back Escape From New York
three starring kressel was announced
today no
really he's gonna be [ __ ]
Kurt Russell's too old to be snake
BlizzCon well we'll see yeah I mean he's
kind of overweight too last I saw him
I haven't seen him well I saw him in
Christmas Chronicles
and he didn't look fat in that
I don't know Ben's still saying that the
sound is low but I mean you were just
listening to it on your device and you
said it sounded normal yeah but I
haven't like I haven't changed yeah any
of the settings or anything like that I
was recording [ __ ] earlier but I didn't
you know what I mean yeah I mean unless
I maybe I can turn it up here is that
you said the intro music sounded normal
could be we're not screaming maybe like
we're not screaming like usual
drunk yet maybe that's what it is yeah
uh casillar Garcia the women is that
pointed toward more towards me instead
of you
maybe I don't know maybe it got maybe it
got moved yeah maybe that's what maybe
it got moved because I probably like hit
it with my arm or something like that
I probably hit it with my arm yeah but
uh yeah yeah you know if
I haven't heard anything about uh Escape
From New York three I haven't heard
anything about that it wouldn't be
called Escape From New York unless it's
Escape From New York again
that would be funny if that's what it
was called yeah that's okay from New
York again yeah
like just a parentheses escape from I
don't know where they work if they
escape from
it could do it
he could probably do it
I don't know I can't really I don't know
like you're gonna have to be like a
he'd have to go on cycle [ __ ] get
back into trying and lose a bunch of fat
he could do it unless he Pokey she's
back there sneezing
Ben says now I can't hear Tom
I don't know why it's like I seriously
did not touch anything I swear to God
you didn't touch anything on here he's
[ __ ] with us
um
yeah all right
oh that's all you were gonna say about
it yeah no yeah bro I'm broke out of my
[ __ ] thing now I can't remember what
I was gonna say Escape From Earth was
the title I heard a few years back
escape from the planet he already did
that basically lockout was Escape From
Earth maybe they're gonna like do that
but yeah with Crystal in it if you watch
lockout that's an escape from New York
that that's a snake [ __ ] movie
it is yeah well wasn't that the original
one I think that was the original script
and they got they got that other guy to
do it uh dude that played uh [ __ ]
Peter Wayland And Prometheus was that
guy's name yeah uh yeah slasher Fred
just brought up lockout yeah Hugo you're
right lockout
and I like to clock out lockout was good
yeah it was pretty good
Ben says extra was an alien ripoff
wasn't it um extra was
kind of I think it was sort of like an
E.T ripoff too but it was like way way
weirder and way darker yeah I did a
video about it over my scare Salon
Channel not too long ago that's a weird
ass [ __ ] movie
it's not it's nothing like alien it's
actually more like E.T but like a
million times more [ __ ] up in a horror
movie you know what I mean it's a lot
more like that
Dave is here hey how are you doing
how's everybody doing out there
man I'm just it's taking me a while to
kind of like get into the swing because
I just got I was so busy today and I
just feel like I was like I got behind
on everything like I had the list my
list of stuff to do and I only got like
half of it done so I was like freaking
out and she had to uh do stuff for
clients yeah so I was like panicking
because I'm just like oh my God we gotta
do like well I gotta do the show and
it's like it's like I'm not ready I'm
not ready you know what I mean so I was
like running around like a crazy person
so you know hopefully I don't like [ __ ]
this show up too bad
so you know I mean I do know a little
bit about this because we've done a show
about it before and to be honest it's
just kind of like we do have like a
couple of British listeners so that'll
be good too and they can maybe like
contribute more because I didn't you
know I didn't live there at the time
that this was going on so I just I lived
there later but I did kind of like hear
about it you know so I do know a little
bit about it but only for like at one
remove you know what I'm saying and I
have seen I haven't seen all the movies
on the nasties list maybe that's one
thing that I should do for my I mean
that'll take a long time but maybe
that's one thing I should do for my
other uh channel is maybe I should go
through all the video nasties and like
watch all of them like all the ones that
were on the list I think all together
like the main list which I think is like
the section one ones which were like
successfully prosecuted or whatever I
think that's 39 movies and then but all
together there's like three different
sections I think and it's like 72 movies
but the weird thing is like
that's the thing I kind of feel like
anything having to do with this type of
censorship it's always going to be like
really arbitrary because it's just gonna
be like I mean there's all these stories
about movies that really aren't that bad
that got because they had like a lurid
cover image or like a [ __ ] up sounding
title or something like that then they
got cut whereas something that was like
way worse like somehow got passed
either because like the people weren't
really watching it that day or they were
just in a different mood or something
like that so everything was like it
seemed like there was there was a lot of
um arbitrariness about it
uh mango said it was a crazy time you
could get hold of the banned movies
though if you knew where to go yeah that
was the thing it was just kind of like
they didn't really stop anybody from
seeing it and much like
I mean it kind of like kicked off this
whole panic but in a lot of ways like
people that were really into horror were
like oh well here's a like a list of
movies we needed to see then you know
what I mean it just like Drew more
attention to him right like like when
maybe if nobody had brought it up like
everyone a lot of them were like really
probably not that great in movies and
probably nobody would even even seen
them you know if somebody hadn't come
out and be like oh my God it's the worst
thing a lot of things a lot of things
governments do backfire they just kind
of you know you got dumb people working
in there hey we're not gonna we're gonna
ban these movies and then everybody will
see them yeah they're like oh thanks for
like compiling a list even back in the
80s the system was porous you could do
it it's just like band of drugs Banning
drugs just means drugs flooded in here
in the United States this is stupid well
and they kind of the way that they
approached this in the UK in the 80s was
very much the way and they I mean I had
like saw like some clips like from back
then of like you know some of the
sensors and stuff like that that like
legit like compared it to drugs like if
you bring these videotapes into their
house like it's just was like bringing
drugs and get to children and won't
somebody thinking the children little
did they know all their Rich political
families invested in the drugs in the
drug Market that's where having all
their political campaigns came a lot of
it came from Drug Money
and it was the same thing man you make
anything illegal especially here in the
United States is defiant As Americans
are you just turned it you turned
something worthless into gold and then
all the rich people run and want to get
involved in that business it's a huge
return
you know you'd be stupid not to deal in
that
well I was reading it's yeah that's the
thing but the thing about it is that I
mean you could argue even though I'm a
big advocate of like drug legalization
um you know what I mean just legalizing
decriminalizes and just like regulating
it the way you would regulate alcohol
don't give it to kids or nothing like
that obviously but we do this that with
alcohol so just do it with drugs yeah
but you could even argue that it's like
it's even dumber with movies because
movies they can't really hurt you I mean
unless you pick up a big ass videotape
and whack somebody upside the head with
it no they thought they could hurt you
that's what I'm saying that's what their
argument was but the thing about it was
let all of these kind of like studies
that they I was watching this
documentary earlier where this one guy
who was a journalist at the time who
thought the whole thing was [ __ ] and
was like trying to come out and like
figure out what it was that they were
talking about because I think initially
one of the arguments that they used they
said oh we did this study and um 40 of
children under eight or something like
that have seen at least one of the
movies on this list and this journalist
like when he was like real raking and he
went and like figured out he's like yeah
this is how they came to the 40 he's
like they sent out a [ __ ] ton of um
questionnaires like to families with
kids under that age and they asked the
kids how many of you have seen these
movies and they're like they got only
like a handful of the things back like
most people didn't bother to send it
back and they said that three of the
kids on the questionnaires that came
back said between them that they had
seen 17 they don't know if the kids
actually saw them but they reported that
they'd seen them between those three
kids it was 17 movies so they did some
math and that they came to like 40 and
they're like so 40 but it was three kids
that said they saw and so like this
other guy was like he had the smart idea
he's like here's what I'm gonna do I'm
gonna send out a questionnaire to a
bunch of little kids and I'm gonna put
like real titles and fake ones on there
and then I'm gonna see if they like say
oh yeah I saw that one and what was in
that what was that one about and these
kids were clear leg pulling [ __ ] out of
their ass yeah they were just just
trying to like be like all badass and
everything oh yeah I saw that one like
somebody's head got cut off it was so
gross blah blah like they were all
saying [ __ ] like that they're like
they're like yeah they're like we made
up those movies those are not real
movies we had a similar thing happen
here in the United States I remember it
I was I was I guess I was probably seven
th sixth seventh eighth grade there was
a Dungeons and Dragons scare yeah where
you had
you had family you had you had like
groups of
family groups you know political groups
Made It by moms supposedly
trying to ban Dungeons and Dragons
because it would get kids to kill kill
other kids just weird [ __ ] like that
that was that they would lose they would
lose grip with reality and yeah they
thought they could really imagine
fictional characters and go out you know
and kill people like they were monsters
and kill monsters and think people were
monsters and then summon the devil and
[ __ ] they made a movie about that called
mazes and monsters with Tom Hank a very
young Tom Hanks yeah it's a cringy movie
yeah I've been wanting to like do it
because it's on 2B yeah so I was like
that would be funny we could talk about
there was like an actual like real case
that kind of uh inspired that but
obviously it was like and man Jack Chick
got all up in that too he made like a
whole bunch of those little his little
like super conservative comics about
about Dungeons and Dragons yeah he had a
bunch of those when we were in seventh
and eighth grade at [ __ ] scma
Southern California Military Academy you
know that's where I was at that time we
all had those Dungeons and Dragons books
and we didn't really play the games we
had the figurines but we just read those
books yeah the books were just cool look
at all the art and stuff yeah the
artwork and everything you know we never
really had a chance to play the games
you know
um
because it took years to figure out how
to play the game so usually by the time
you figured out how to play it you'd
kind of an artist yeah
this video is too much effort yeah video
games started to come yeah but they were
real good books and
good artwork you know Errol Otis was
like a [ __ ] famous artist that the
commercial type artist that came out
there and it was the same thing it was
this [ __ ] moral panic and then it
turned out that behind this were
churches churches were behind the moral
Panic they didn't like anything that
could compete with the church
and anything that referenced magic and
monsters and demons that it had tried to
stamp that out now in the United States
if you're not an American
there is no organized Church really in
the United States every there's like 20
30 40 different competing versions of
Christianity depending on what region
you're in you know again methodists and
Baptists and you know Southern Baptists
and Catholics and they don't have any
government power
but they'd put them on television like
they did
and you had political parties Cowtown to
them I mean if they cry if they cry
enough then yeah they can get [ __ ]
passed yeah political parties just start
Cowtown to them a lot of that [ __ ]
they'd pass it and I don't I'd forget
all about anything ever coming out of it
because that's another thing you know
it's big money to pass laws and it you
make a lot of money trying to pass laws
and being a politician you make a lot of
money
whether or not those laws are actually
in applied or enforced or make a
difference
a lot of times nothing ever gets any
traction on the ground because because
each state has its own legal system and
there's 50 states in here and then
a lot of it never really
a lot of it a lot of there's no Mecca
there's no mechanism for enforcement
and people just kind of do whatever they
want anyway
you ask the American you ask the average
American they really couldn't tell you
what what's legal or not legal they just
don't they know that you can't steal and
you can't rape and you can't kill people
you can't set things on fire and you
don't want to get caught with drugs
other than that you know they don't know
the laws
doesn't matter you don't have much
contact with with law enforcement unless
you're out there [ __ ] in some kind of
drug war
or drunk driving a lot you know you you
can drink and drive you just can't be so
[ __ ] drunk that you call attention to
yourself
Ben says did you see the movie censor a
year or so ago I did it's awesome uh
that was actually one of my favorite
horror movies that I saw in the last
couple years
um yeah that's a really really good
movie if you haven't seen it and it's
kind of about this it's about a woman
that um that worked for the bbfc the
British Board of film sensors which they
later called the British border film
classification which I was like okay we
still know what you're up to but they
were like badlerizing that word
um yeah uh Ben also says in Australia
all R-rated movies were banned from sale
in Queensland which is a very
conservative state so every horror
slasher movie would Proclaim band in
Queensland on their cover
that's what I mean it's like they're
just working against themselves you're
just they're just working against
themselves uh John Smith said yep when I
was a kid Mom and Pop video shops were
still a thing and a lot of them kept a
supply under the counter if you had
money and no one else was in the shop
say it's for my dad yeah I mean
I kind of feel like most people could
get them but
you know it's it's just kind of like uh
I kind of feel like and like I said I
was watching a documentary I watched a
couple documentaries earlier today about
this whole phenomenon
and a couple of them pointed out they
said well the thing about it was that
you know at this point I think Thatcher
had been in for a couple of years at
this stage and you know they always
wanted to look like they were tough on
crime bloody blah because crime had been
getting a lot worse and so you know a
lot of people have speculated that they
decided they were gonna like have this
huge moral panic and pick on these
horror movies because most of the
Distributors of this were like not rich
like you know it was just Mom and Pop
video shops like I said you know most of
the people that made these movies they
were just like underground exploitation
movies they couldn't really fight back
and it was like an easy scapegoat you
know it's really really easy just like
every time something bad happens
everybody says oh violent video games or
you know something like that something
like innocuous that you know obviously
is not the cause for that because it's
much easier to just blame that thing
than blame like larger systemic forces
which are you know it's a lot more
complicated and more like harder to
tease out so it's like it's really easy
to like stir up outrage against one one
thing you know what I mean and um in
particular I think like the video
nasties thing in the UK uh The Daily
Mail was like a big huge uh part of like
how that got exploded so much because
they were always ban the sadist videos
they'd put it on there like really big
so you know and they were selling a lot
of papers like a little crotchety old
ladies because they'd never seen any of
those movies they didn't know what the
[ __ ] was going on they just heard about
stuff that those are the ones you want
to get it's much better
just tell them this happened oh okay
well we gotta stop that yeah that's the
kind of [ __ ] they would do here
sometimes there's only one movie that
should have never been made and I think
some people should have gone to jail for
it's a damn Italian movie with a
cannibal movie where they were cutting
up all those animals
Holocaust yeah well that's definitely on
the nastiest one yeah that dude should
have gone to prison for that and in the
UK it's still the animal cruelty is
still okay yeah no they said they don't
I mean generally like nowadays
um you know they don't usually they said
you know even later movies like Hospital
like the hospital series and stuff like
that which are a million times worse
than anything you saw back then
um most of those pass you know with no
Cuts or minimal Cuts but
um yeah they they said one thing they do
have a lot of problems with is real
animal cruelty like if you have a real
animal cruelty they will cut that I've
tried to watch that [ __ ] until that dude
grabbed that karate a little quiet
Monday has stuck that stick through it
and I was like I don't know how to [ __ ]
this [ __ ] I'll turn that off I didn't
want anything to do with that and that
was back in the 70s but I I just uh I'm
like man they killed that animal just
just so it could be on a movie that's
[ __ ] wrong yeah that's [ __ ] up
that's what I that's one thing stick
that's one thing
um I would argue like I'm you know I'm a
very anti-censorship person but you know
there are limits like I said you know
you can't just like make a [ __ ] snuff
film obviously and so I kind of feel
like that's along the same lines because
you're not I mean I don't have a problem
with you know because you could say
something like Apocalypse Now or they
did actually but well they ate that and
it's like they would have done it anyway
if you're just doing it for a movie
though then [ __ ] that and that and that
was just a regular ritual Slaughter they
just cut that cow's head off
and they show it in slow motion to make
it look more graphic than what it really
is but if you saw that I think it was it
slightly in slow motion I think it was
if
that cow didn't feel that it went down
and they severed that spinal column
[ __ ] instantly that cow went didn't
know what happened what hit it but that
was food
you know yeah they were they were
planning to eat that they didn't torture
it you know if I can stick it down blunt
stick through a little quart of money or
cut a turtle up open alive and just you
know that that Cannibal Holocaust movie
that now that dude should have gone to
prison for that everybody involved in
that [ __ ] went to prison for that that
he did get called up to trial but they
they were I mean they weren't really
they were worried about animals they
thought that the people really got
killed too but that's kind of why
because the animal cruelty in that is
absolutely real yeah I can't believe
that that dude so I don't the actors
should have done time for doing that you
couldn't put me on there and say hey man
we're paying you stick this stick this
is quite a month it's all right I got it
there's no way I would not say [ __ ] no I
quit yeah nope not doing it yeah you
know and I [ __ ] kill squirrels and
deer and [ __ ] but I eat all that
dude I was asked I was watching not too
long ago
uh I was watching you you remember that
cheesy 70s movie Kingdom the spiders
yeah with the shot is stepping on the
Tarantulas yeah I couldn't even watch
that I like spiders but that's the thing
I was just kind of like did they really
kill that job like [ __ ] this movie I was
like oh my God I don't even like him to
kill spiders in movies or bugs or
anything I Saw movies it was kind of a
vet kind of has a value to it you know
what I mean it's not the same as like
you've seen them crushing roaches you
know those are Vermin you know they're
everywhere
uh but I've seen movies where they step
on roaches or [ __ ] spray a roach [ __ ]
that's nothing you know yeah that
doesn't bother but she doesn't like
roaches I think I think
you could say well you know a scorpion
or a scorpion or a tarantulas only
thirty dollars or forty dollars it still
that's kind of an exotic
you know animal kinda
you know it's something you get from a
pet store
um obviously in the United States he's
like you know that's not really that's
not too cool that's a big ant it's a big
arthropod you know you could say well
you eat you eat the crabs yeah but
you're not killing crabs for a movie
yeah I think that's the distinction it's
like the just it's like the
entertainment value yeah I mean I kind
of like because I do kind of feel like
in the United States at least like you
know it obviously was a lot more lacks
back then nowadays
um they I don't think they would allow
you to do that because they would have
like pretty much any movie that's gonna
have any kind of animal in it what
insects or not or insects or arthropods
or whatever they're gonna have somebody
there monitoring that [ __ ] because they
don't I mean obviously it might happen
where some of them get hurt and stuff
like that but they do have somebody
monitoring it you're not just allowed to
kill them for and now that they have CGI
there's really no reason for that to
occur movies are entertainment you gotta
have a [ __ ] basic respect for life
you know yeah exactly and even if you're
shooting Apocalypse Now and you got
tribal people out there slaughtering a
it wasn't I don't think it was a cow it
was a water buffalo wasn't it oh yeah
yeah yeah it was it was it was an ox or
a water buffalo yeah and they slaughter
it but that's what they eat you know and
it was during and it was all set up some
kind of ritual they were going to do
that anyway they just included it in the
movie I don't know that's what I'm
saying that's why I don't have a problem
yeah I have a problem with that either
because they ate that that's part of
their life cycle you know [ __ ] every
time you predators and prey relationship
you know animals eating one another
humans eating other animals that's all
part of the cycle of life since millions
and billions of years you know that's
just how it is but you just don't put an
animal on [ __ ] screen and kill it for
no [ __ ] reason just to have it on a
damn movie and then they don't eat it
and then they were torturing them in in
in in on in Cannibal Holocaust that's
that's
unacceptable
you know yeah so that's kind of one no
you know what I mean it's like look I'm
a big horror movie fan I'm just like I'm
of the opinion that if the [ __ ] is fake
um I would even go to bat for a Serbian
film which is you know which is a
terrible I mean it's it's a it's a
beautifully shot movie but
it's uh it's not something that you
really want to watch to be honest with
you because like it has the worst [ __ ]
ever in it but it's fake
um and even if I don't personally want
to sit through it again I'm not gonna
sit here and argue that like nobody
should ever see it or that they
shouldn't have made it or something like
that it's fake faking you out is an art
form that goes way back man they were
trying to fake you out back in the late
1800s early 1900s with special effects
and evidently they were do they had I
think it was in France they were doing
live acts on stage that you today you'd
call a slasher film yeah but it was
stuff that they would do on stage live
in Texas yeah they would try to convince
you that they just killed somebody or
did something to somebody yeah it was
fake though they were hardcore yeah like
sticking something yeah that was like a
big thing that was like a big art form
back in the day like I said Grand Canyon
that's what they called it that was like
the theater and that was like that was a
source of Pride for them it's like how
realistic could they like make so people
have always wanted to do that yeah and
I'm not informed was that it was fake
yeah and they're making you think it's
real yeah and that's the whole thing I
think that's the thing that people and I
think the main problem when when you
have people because if you saw like some
of the clips like from the 80s of the
people that were on the bbfc back that
were watching all these movies because
they did watch all the movies I mean to
be fair but it's like these were like
the most rickety like Boomer uptight
[ __ ] they were just like these
really really elderly you know they
really didn't have any idea at all about
exploitation Cinema about the value of
it it's like they didn't like horror
movies they thought they were trashy
it's like all this other kind of [ __ ]
and it's like
You Know It Horror has like a really
long
storied history it's not just this you
know red-headed stepchild but I mean I
kind of feel like in the 70s and 80s it
still was so it was like really easy to
like kick around you know what I mean
because it's like oh well you know smart
people are upper class people or
something like that like they don't like
that kind of thing because it's beneath
them so it was like really really easy
because I do kind of feel like maybe
more than you know the similar moral
panics that we had in the US about like
horror comics and stuff like that
because we had a similar thing happen I
think in the 50s and 60s but
um I kind of feel like in the UK there
was a very specific like class thing to
it as well because you definitely had
like all the dudes and ladies that were
on the bbfc were like very kind of like
middle to upper class and they were like
oh well we can sit here and watch these
movies all day long and say oh we should
cut that we should cut that we should
cut that but it's like we're protecting
the hoi polloi who are maybe too stupid
to you know be able to deal with these
so like I said it seemed it came across
as very arrogant to me because they were
saying that we can see these but you you
know you don't have the fortitude to
watch them because they sat there and
watched every single one of them
sometimes several times and it's like oh
well they didn't think they were going
to become depraved by watching that
stuff and some of them even kind of said
that outright it was like oh it's not us
we're worried about it's you know those
people yeah it's more it's poor people
it's poor people yeah they might yeah
they thought that poor people like would
be too easily influenced but of course
they wouldn't be right which to me like
that was kind of like the Crux of the
whole matter it's just still going on
today
well that's the thing and it's like I
said it was a very specifically class
conscious thing in the UK which I I
don't know if there was so much I guess
there was a little bit of a class
component like in the US but there's
always like the class thing is always
way more pronounced when you're talking
about the UK because well it's weird
though because I kind of feel like and
having lived there and like known a lot
of British people in my time
um they think it's kind of funny because
they're like well yeah the class thing
is a lot more pronounced in the UK but
like they're a lot more aware of it they
said there's still a class thing in in
the U.S but everybody pretends like
there's not
and I was like yeah I guess that's true
but like over there they're like a lot
more aware of it because it's like well
kind of like
um I disagree with that because uh in
the United States is if you go up the
socioeconomic system uh uh go up the
socioeconomic ladder they don't become
more moral here they become less
less well I'm not talking about morality
necessarily I'm just talking about like
in the UK
there's a lot of
um there's kind of a lot of things like
to higher up you are like the you know
the way they talk or like you know the
things that they own like the things
that they do stuff like that it's like
very very stratified I don't know about
nowadays like it might be different now
it probably is but I do kind of feel
like that's something that is a little
bit different like in the US but that
was definitely a component of the video
a lot of the feelings of false morality
in the United States come from the upper
middle class and the Very Nuvo rich like
the people that haven't had a lot of
money for a long time they kind of have
that attitude but real rich people here
are indistinguishable from criminals
they're just like drug cartel type
leaders or whatever they buy and sell
people they
they have [ __ ] pleasure islands like
[ __ ] out of them Caligula and stuff you
know they're they're bad
and this is now proven that that's the
way they are
they buy and sell people they have
[ __ ] exploitation rings and
everything's [ __ ] gamified and it's
just a bunch of rackets and uh a lot of
them have been around for [ __ ]
Generations
because of this old money and they're
just if you if you were to meet them and
they they uh
uh they evidently don't they don't
comport themselves very well uh the
English that they use is [ __ ] pretty
bad uh they cost a lot and uh
they're just they're not people you'd
want to hang out with well I cuss a lot
yeah that's what I'm actually talking
about I'm talking about they're not
genteel people that's a middle class
thing they're uh they're more like
gangsters well that's kind of like the
UK too it's like you you get people that
are middle class or like are aspire to
be upper class and they're a lot more
proper exactly than people that are
actually upper class because people that
are actually upper class and have had
money they're whole if they don't have
to impress anyone because they've had
money their whole life so they're not
trying to like Aspire or like be
something that they're not because
they're already that so they can just
act however because they can get away
with whatever yep you know what I mean
but I will say that multiple Studies
have shown just as just as a sideline
that people that swear a lot are tend to
be more intelligent yeah well that's why
I'm not really sure just look at me why
granther says I'm way behind on the
comments granther says uh wasn't faces
of death banned in the U.S or at least
that's what we told each other in eighth
grade during our secret yeah horror
movie parties yeah we say that yeah it's
like yeah then we go down and rent it
remember go to Blockbuster and rent this
[ __ ] this is bad we're [ __ ] uh
Blockbuster didn't happen with New York
video or what was the name of that other
one something it was a Hollywood Video
Hollywood Video I think that was it was
the red and white one I think that was
yellow and white though I can't remember
I thought it was the one I went to was
movie gallery yeah he said oh this
shit's bad man you must be watching that
let's rent it yeah
but when you're a teenager
we're gonna rent it then okay let's run
it yeah we're gonna rent this banned
movie there was more than one Faces of
Death it was a whole series yeah they
all kind of sucked
well there was real [ __ ] in there and
fake [ __ ] in there and a lot of the [ __ ]
's fake was not really that well faked
yeah and a lot of the [ __ ] that was real
was like National Geographic type [ __ ]
and a lot of it was kind of like you
know animal cruelty and that kind of
stuff which like man I don't really want
to watch that that's not a good time I
mean I didn't know it was fake animal
cruelty well yeah the monkey eating the
monkey brains that was fake yeah that
was fake but that well that's the thing
it's like I can't that's oh that's
another good idea that I should do over
my other channel like watching all the
faces of death and like figure it out
like outfit because I haven't seen him
in such a long time but that's well the
thing I wasn't impressed even at the
time no I remember not being impressed
either because like it had such a
reputation it's like all this is real oh
my God like it's a documentary and like
fake documentary too yeah
this is a shitty documentary just the
voiceover it's like these special
effects and they're just trying to
murder they're trying to they're trying
to join they're trying to join one
subject to the next and they're the way
they are linked together is just fake as
[ __ ] you can tell that they just have a
bunch of random footage that they have
to show that they're trying that they're
trying to show you all of it and they're
trying to connect this [ __ ] it's a fake
documentary
of like a guy in an electric chair right
yeah that was fake I know it was but
it's like yeah I kind of remember that I
kind of remember one wasn't there an
alligator eating the person yeah and
then the guy that was on stage and
something fell on his head that had a
blade on it that looked fake oh that's
right the guy who shot himself on
television I think that might have been
real oh that was real because that's
that's like a famous case yeah that's
happened more than once but that that
one I can't remember the dude's name but
like that yeah that dude was like
actually like pretty famous like he shot
himself on live TV yeah wait was it a
dude or was it a woman a dude because I
thought a woman did it once too but he
was a news reporter he was yeah yeah
yeah
yeah I remember that yeah I didn't see
it like when it happened but I remember
hearing about it so that yeah that was
himself live on television this show is
real
but it wasn't too impressive
that's why they showed it I guess yeah
that's the thing yeah but you're like
man dude shot himself
yeah yeah
honestly a lot of times like if you see
the real [ __ ]
it doesn't look as I mean it because in
a horror movie they want it to look
cinematic so they're gonna like
exaggerate it if you see it in real life
a lot of times it doesn't really look as
cool as like you know not always but I
still remember they did show and I don't
know if some of these were fake but you
remember in um driver's ed like in high
school where they showed you those
movies like blood on the highway and all
that kind of stuff which was purportedly
uh videos of like real accidents which
I'm sure some of them probably were I
don't know oh some of that [ __ ] was I
remember it but well the one I remember
specifically was it was these two old
people it was an elderly couple and
their car I think had gone off in
overpass and then it caught fire
and so they pulled and they showed him
like pulling their like barbecued bodies
out of there and that was pretty [ __ ]
gross how about the guy that they pulled
out of the car and threw him on the damn
stretcher and his [ __ ] Jaws [ __ ]
his Jaws
I can't even remember that one slapping
around I remember having to have like a
permission slip and everything like that
like Hey we're gonna show your kids like
this really [ __ ] up [ __ ] today yeah
that's when you were in high school
Raptors remembers it I remember
Grandpa's remember you're in high school
and you got to go through driver's ed
you gotta you got to go early they're
scaring you straight yeah you got to go
early before school was open got to go
through driver's Ed's uh course and that
went on on about a month I guess to get
your driver's permit
and part of it is just before you go out
and [ __ ] drive they're the safety
part they show you all the damn snuff
flicks of all the dead people that got
killed and of course you take it
seriously yeah and it is effective it is
it's effective to show you to show you
what happens if you [ __ ] up
but uh me and grafters man we were
driving I think we were 16 weren't we
in the United States you drive you're
driving to 16 or 17. they've got
Learners permits you can get a learner's
permit at 15. and then you can get your
regular at least that's how it was when
I was that age because I got a learner's
permit when I was 15 and that you can
get your license when you're 16. like
you're following year that's what it was
it might have been 15 or 16. Grandpa's
probably remember he I don't know if we
were in the same in the same driver's
class but he I'm sure he got his [ __ ] at
Trenton High also but um and then the
[ __ ]
that driver's ed teacher I forgot his
name you remember the short sleeve shirt
and his [ __ ] glasses he had to birth
control glasses in his [ __ ] tie
and now you're gonna drive good he's
like that but he yeah he was something
else I do remember that guy
but uh it would be dark out it'd be so
early
we'd have to show up five o'clock in the
morning still dark out
to do driver's ed
and then eventually you [ __ ] driving
man and then later on your [ __ ]
driver's license shows up
I tried to tell that to a Japanese girl
one time that we were driving at 15 16
and that blew her mind man
because they don't drive that early
yeah I mean you can drive at 15 you can
get a learner's permit yeah but you
can't drive by yourself you always have
to have like an older driver in the car
with you unless unless you're going to
or from work then they give you like
you're not supposed to drive at night
either and you never get pulled over no
it's like they don't know they can't
tell how old you are you're just driving
like unless you look like a child in
which case they might yeah you know
um let me see uh Danny Rowling said
first time I saw a house on the edge of
the park uh blew me away I couldn't
believe what I just saw like I was
watching a rape genre of porno it was
awesome no films grip my attention like
that film did I remember that yeah I
remember that movie that was definitely
like on the nasties list too and
honestly like there was a lot
I mean I haven't seen that for a really
long time but I remember the one like uh
I Spit on Your Grave being on there
which like I said I will even though
that is a really really unpleasant movie
to watch because like the rape scene in
that is really really long and like
really
um really unpleasant but I would defend
that movie I would defend that movie
because they're showing uh rape like it
would actually happen like it's not
titillating it's not sexy it's not and
they're I don't think you're even
supposed to be titillated by you're
supposed to be horrified by it so that's
kind of the whole point all right
grandpas came back because it was six
a.m the driver's ed Mr Matthews man he
remembers all those [ __ ] Matthews
that's right
he says we were juniors in high school
okay so we were about 16 I think then
right
15 or 16. I don't remember what how old
a junior was
two years about 16. I think sophomore is
15. okay he said he said I had a bunch
of hotties in my driver's ed class
always popping wood during those like
okay yeah I understand that
yeah
Ben says uh those shops presumably the
ones that had the video nasties uh
happily sold cigarettes and booze to
Children including individual cigarettes
to school kids they didn't care about
selling or hiring videos yeah I kind of
feel like because I think at least from
my understanding I think cable and
satellite TV
kind of caught on quicker in the U.S
than it did in the UK so conversely the
UK
um the Home Video Market started like
booming over there before it started
booming over here you know what I mean
so because they didn't really have the
same extent of like cable and satellite
TV so everybody was going and renting
movies and at least in my understanding
like people that grew up during that
time period that I've talked to they
said yeah like pretty much every corner
shop had like a [ __ ] ton of videos that
you could rent because that's just what
you did you know what I mean like there
wasn't anything else to watch so you
know so so you could get them everywhere
and there was ones like under the
counter too yeah and John Smith is
talking about the Damned song uh yeah
they did a song called uh video nasty
I'm in love with a video nasty actually
that was on uh young ones they had an
episode called Nasty that had the Damned
on there which is actually my favorite
episode that was one where Alexi sale
was a vampire from South Africa winning
from the trans ball or something like I
haven't seen it a long time but that was
like that's like a really funny [ __ ]
episode and they went and like rented
like a vcr and it was like 1982 or some
[ __ ] like that
Richard Brown said Thatcher got in 1979
that's right I thought it was like
sometime around then
um let's see oh what I was gonna say um
a long time ago was that Blockbuster
we didn't actually where I lived uh
growing up in Daytona Beach we didn't
actually get a blockbuster until
probably like the 90s like the mid 90s
and prior to that we had kind of gone to
more like Mom and Pop video shops the
kind with like you know the the porn in
the back
Blockbuster because they were more of
like a large chain uh they did not have
porn and they also would not stock
anything over an R
and even then like a lot of movies if
there was a movie that was like kind of
questionable like had some like [ __ ]
up [ __ ] in it you couldn't get it there
or you could only get like a cut version
because I remember that happening
because I was really into horror because
and once Blockbuster took over and like
kind of put all the other like Mom and
Pop video shops out of business at least
where I grew up
um it was really really difficult to get
hold of kind of more extreme horror
movies or more obscure horror movies
because Blockbuster didn't have them
it's like no man we we just want to have
like 40 bajillion copies of you know
whatever the big [ __ ] movie was that
year like Titanic or whatever we have
like 50 000 copies of that but you can't
have like this one
horror Indie movie so a lot of times I
would either have to and that was a
before they really had the internet to
any great degree so a lot of times I'd
have to like stock up and like buy them
through like magazine ads or I'd have to
like wait till I went to New York City
and like you know go to Kim's or
something like that and like stock up on
[ __ ] there because you couldn't get it
you couldn't rent them
um Blockbuster didn't have a lot of that
kind of stuff they and um also too they
had
um I didn't know if you know this but
Walmart they sold DVDs you know and
movies and stuff but they would only
sell the cup versions too so you
couldn't get like uncut editions of
stuff I think people take it for granted
nowadays how easy it is to get like [ __ ]
that you want anything you want that's
like uncut it's like even if you can't
get it in this country just order it
from like another country it's like no
problem at all and if you have a VPN you
can watch [ __ ] on streaming services
from like other countries and it's like
super easy but back then it was a pain
in the ass
and you never knew like what you were
getting it's like what was cut out of
this you you might order something that
says it's uncut and it wasn't and it's
like all kind of stations was there for
[ __ ] out there you didn't even know
existed right exactly like you'd be in
some band like boss and
there have been videos that you didn't
know that there was a video for that
song because there was nowhere where
there was no no place where it was
compiled there was all these different
merchants and different distributors and
you didn't know what was out there you
just find something look what I found
you know look at this album I didn't
know this existed
you know it was just the way it was back
then
yeah that's true it was much harder like
I said that's why I mean I think we kind
of like romanticized that time period
And even to it at such an extent that
people that are really into horror
movies especially people that are like
our age
um they kind of like they're they're
kind of like we only want to see like
the video nasties but we want to see
them like they were back then like on
really really shitty like VHS because
it's not it's not the same experience
like seeing them all cleaned up and
everything like that it's like you want
it to kind of look like it's all [ __ ]
Sleazy and you know like you're not
supposed to be watching it that like
kind of adds to the whole experience
which I get that I get that but
uh because because they were saying
earlier like how um the one guy was
saying how he has a hard time like
watching Texas Chainsaw Massacre like
the all remastered and everything like
that he's like because I'm so used to
like just seeing this shitty old beat up
VHS where it was almost like Black and
White because it had been like
re-recorded so many times yeah that's
why you know sometimes I'll
I'll stay on the show how you know I
like the The Flash Gordon you know with
uh the dino to the rentals Flash Gordon
most people had only seen that on
television and it looked like [ __ ] on
television
I saw it in the theater twice it looked
[ __ ] great the the costumes and
everything it didn't look cheap on film
it looked real expensive but it looks
cheap when they when it got on the cable
so I'm glad that I got that Blu-ray and
the HD television you see it it's like
it was on the theater man it looked
great it was a wacky [ __ ] flick but
it was I was so pissed that they never
came out with a sequel but you know
I liked it better than Star Wars
it's a fun movie I liked it yeah at the
time
I had sex and drugs in it well yeah
princess Zara that always helps I have
BDSM in it I was [ __ ] I was loving it
man I was like this it was it was Goofy
but the source material was Goofy you
know yeah it's okay yeah
uh slasher friend said if you guys ever
see that movie called Grindhouse yeah I
like that one uh that movie pays homage
to the classic 70s exploitation movies I
actually saw that in the theater with
the in-between trailer when it was a
double feature you know what I mean like
with the trailers in between and like
the fake trailers and stuff that was
like a fun experience now they have it
as two separate movies like now they
have it as Death Proof and Planet Terror
and then like you just have to watch but
I went and saw it in the theater when
they showed both movies back to back
like with all those fake trailers in the
middle and that was like really really
cool so I'm sure you can probably still
get it like that
um John Smith said uh yeah Christian
weirdos such as Mary Whitehouse had a
lot to answer for yeah Mary Whitehouse
uh she's like you look up old bitty in
the dictionary and there she is you know
what one of the funniest things about
the okay because she became
um in the UK she kind of became the most
visible
face of um of the video nasty panic and
uh you know kind of since Punk and all
that kind of stuff was going on at the
time too like I thought it was funny
that actually one producer of porn
magazines like made a porn magazine
called White House like named after her
so she would get offended so I thought
that was like super funny
um let's see uh Ben says protecting
children and the mentally feeble who
might be correct corrupted by evil films
uh John Smith said I think the bbfc had
a thing for violence that could be
imitated yeah that's the thing I kind of
feel like a lot like I said a lot of
their [ __ ] seemed like kind of arbitrary
and they even a couple of them even said
that because I saw some interviews like
from the time period and the guy was
like well we don't have any rules
specifically it's just kind of like they
have to take everything on a
case-by-case basis so it's like
sometimes they would pass some [ __ ]
um and then sometimes they wouldn't pass
[ __ ] like that seemed more mild than
that but they always seem to have like
the the rationale like you said that
they thought someone could imitate it
like one of the Rambo movies I remember
it wasn't a video nasty or anything like
that but when they were talking about
um you know cuts to it they said they
were actually more bothered
by because you know in the rain I don't
remember if it was Rambo 2 or I don't
remember which rainbow movie it was but
it was one of the Rambo movies that has
like a 15 minute sequence of just
basically Rambo shooting everybody
um they're like they were less bothered
by that than they were like one scene
with a kid like with a knife going like
oh I'm gonna be like Rambo you know I
mean because they thought oh if a kid
sees that like he'll relate to that kid
and maybe he'll go and pick up a knife
and stab somebody you know what I mean
yeah it's afraid that people will mimic
it we'll mimic it what you could see
that that would apply to anything
that's what I'm saying that's what I'm
saying if you take that to its logical
conclusion you can't show anybody
anything then you can't show anybody
anything because it's like you can't you
can mimic it and yeah and the thing
about it is like well particularly
movies too it's like you really have to
take context into consideration because
it's like you can't just like pick and
choose like little bits of things
because that's not I mean in service of
The Wider story
you know and somebody was saying this
earlier and we've kind of said this a
lot too because we talk a lot about
serial killers and [ __ ] like that it's
like if you talk about stuff like that
that doesn't mean you're like advocating
for it or like you think it's okay or
you think it's cool or anything like
that if you show something to somebody
it doesn't mean that they do it and if
you show something in a movie that
doesn't mean that you're saying hey this
is cool yeah you know what I mean the
whole point of a horror movie is to
freak you out and to scare you and to
horrify you so they're showing you
imagery that's supposed to be you're not
really supposed to be watching going
awesome I'm gonna do that here's the
thing most crimes that happen are pretty
mundane they don't have anything to do
with what was seen in a movie like dudes
aren't robbing liquor stores because
they saw it in a movie they're robbing
liquor stores because they need drug
buddy right okay yeah that's very
practical it's very practical all right
and you know there's nothing to do with
what they saw in a movie and then when
you look at the [ __ ] real heinous
serial killers none of that was shown in
the movie really they made that up on
their own had the movies had nothing to
do with what John Wayne Gacy was doing
well I saw this movie and then that gave
me the idea yes I was attracted to these
young guys and was raping and torturing
and putting them in the bottom you know
in the walls of his house and down in
the crawl spaces and I thought that'd be
a good idea to inspired me you know no
that's not what happened that's what I
aspire to yeah that had that's not how
I'm gonna put that on my dream board
and it's not like it's not like uh oh
[ __ ] no what's his name [ __ ] uh
[ __ ] man I'm drawing a blank the best
Serial Killer Of All Times uh the Bundy
the best so yeah body okay the best one
of all time best in best well he didn't
see a movie about a dude who's going out
raping and killing all these beautiful
women they're cutting their heads off
right yeah that had nothing to do with
the movie it had to do with his it
turned out his sister was his mom and
his mom was his grandma and uh he was an
underachiever and and he just was [ __ ]
up you know
um women kept dumping him and uh he lost
his [ __ ] mind it didn't have anything
to do with movies
zero I would argue that if you are a
completely normal person and then see a
horror movie and suddenly say I'm that's
a good idea I'm gonna do that [ __ ] then
uh you're not a normal person because
most normal and honestly here's the
thing and I always kind of bring this
example up look at a country like Japan
Japan they have some [ __ ] up movies
you know really way worse than ours holy
[ __ ] have you seen some of those movies
Korea too like to a lesser extent yeah
they have super super low crime rate so
that's obviously not what's causing the
crime because they have way way way more
violent [ __ ] Dean Coral who I think was
what was [ __ ] one of the worst ones
the Candyman oh man
he had this teenage boy that would go
out and recruit other teenage boys and
bring him back in time to a board and
torture him and [ __ ] stick glass rods up
in there [ __ ]
urethras and break it with [ __ ]
pliers and [ __ ]
he even got two brothers to attempt to
beat each other to death so one of them
could live that's how he was the ex-army
leather daddy that's like some saw [ __ ]
right yeah like somebody saw dude but
that came later see right and that was
what late 70s early 80s something like
that I can't remember it had nothing to
do with movies he didn't he didn't watch
any movie to do that movies weren't
influenced I mean they came up with that
[ __ ] oh this is all internal perversions
people that act on it well and very
deep-rooted problem in them
um just it's gonna be [ __ ] something
biologically something chemically wrong
with them mixing with a bad upbringing
and notably I would argue that yeah for
example uh you know there was a big like
I don't know Texas Chainsaw Massacre I
don't think was ever considered a video
nasty but it was one that a lot of
people brought up even though if you
haven't seen Texas Chainsaw Massacre in
a long time really the most lurid thing
about it is its title uh yeah some
[ __ ] up [ __ ] happens in it but a lot
of it is suggested they don't really
show anything but like I think that's
why it's such a great movie because it's
all implication but the thing about
Texas Chainsaw Massacre is that it's
Loosely based on a real guy yeah horror
movies have to take ideas from these
[ __ ] it's not the other way
around you know they already came up
with that [ __ ] on their own and then
horror maybe people are like holy crap
that's some [ __ ] up [ __ ] I'm gonna
make a movie about that I couldn't even
think of that because I'm a normal
person movies don't create those guys no
not at all those guys are kind of born
and developed like that they're already
like that that is their I guess you
could say that is their sexual
orientation and you can't
you can't show somebody a movie and get
them to do that no it's a lot more
deeper it's deeper you know they're born
and raised to to do that and then
there's a whole bunch of problems in
them I think genetically
it's not a normal person I don't think
because because you can abuse little
kids have been abused and [ __ ] when they
grow up normal
yeah you know it's a it's a bunch of
factors that have to that's what I'm
saying a lot of things have to like come
together in like the worst possible way
to produce somebody like that some of it
has to be if you ask me biological yeah
I'm sure it's a problem somewhere in
there
and then it's exacerbated by but see not
always because a lot of times like
sometimes serial killers like they have
like a relatively normal upbringing yeah
um you know and they still turn out
[ __ ] up but that's rarer uh I will say
that but it does happen hormones are
very powerful I always wanted to know
these serial killers I need to go in
there and do a blood analysis test on
them and look and see if they're
actually producing testosterone and if
the testosterone they're producing is it
a mutant strain of it is something more
like nandralone maybe or maybe it's
something a little bit more like
trendbolone because some of that [ __ ] is
mind-alterings I I bet you there's
something biological wrong going on in
there in the in the endocrine system
uh you know
I [ __ ] around with some weird ass
[ __ ] hormones and steroids and [ __ ]
like that and that it is mind-altering
and I bet you they're not producing
normal
hormones well there's got to be
something that matter with that because
it's and like I said I don't it's keyed
in with sex drive and I don't think
that's the only thing going on I think
that it has to have be like a perfect
storm of a lot of different things I've
read that and the endocrine system will
sit there and it'll try to pump out a
certain hormone and not all the little
hormone total [ __ ] compounds that
it's making are perfect some of them are
more imperfect it's not quite the same
hormone but it doesn't add up to enough
but that dude might be making lots of it
lots of something that's [ __ ] up and
it maybe it acts more like nadralone or
something than it does testosterone I
just I bet you they never really looked
at that
I don't know I kind of feel like that's
something that they would have liked do
you think they would have looked at that
I mean you would think because they
looked at like most other like genetic
kind of components so I don't know I had
I never looked it up so I wouldn't yeah
I mean that seems like something that
seems yeah they're making testosterone
but it's a weird variant of it maybe
that is slightly mind-altering more
aggression more sex drive more into the
damn what do you call it
um uh make it bloodthirsty and uh
sadistic which I imagine there's
probably hormones that can do that
yeah Ben says uh Mary Whitehouse had a
huge influence and she was basically a
busybody puritanical housewife yep
that's pretty much it and she like I
said she kind of became the face of the
whole video nasty thing which is it's
funny because I believe
um I believe that it was the makers of
Cannibal Holocaust and they were trying
to drum up uh publicity for their film
so they sent Mary Whitehouse an
anonymous letter complaining about their
own movie because they were hoping to
get the Streisand Effect going which
they didn't call it that back then but
it's the same thing Richard Brown
brought up a good egg but well I'm like
way behind on the comments because yeah
so I'm trying to like catch up on
everybody but um
but yeah I forgot what I was talking
about never mind I guess it wasn't
important
um so anyway uh mr88 says uh benwell's
Lodge Door which is a golden age I guess
shows a close-up of a woman's eyeball
being sliced over the razor I thought
that was
um Andalusian Dog the Salvador Dali one
which they actually they did show the
the razor in the eye it was actually
like a cow's eyeball so it was actually
a razor slicing an eyeball this just
obviously wasn't a person's eye
um Richard Brown said Americans talk
about class more than the British do
yeah like I said it's been a long time
so I haven't been over there so I don't
really know uh we need to eat the rich
yeah okay they're probably delicious
well marbled you know what I mean uh
let's see
yeah that's what that Andalusian Dog
that that's what I was just saying
Keeping Up Appearances I remember that
show
yeah that's Danny rolling says uh and
yeah I remember this too in England they
weren't even allowed to have uh
Michelangelo the orange bandana Ninja
Turtle have nunchucks which is [ __ ]
yeah um they actually called them
Teenage Mutant what do they call them
Teenage Mutant something Turtles but
they they could say ninja yeah they
couldn't say ninja what the [ __ ] was it
maybe Warrior no
I can't remember what it was and yeah
they specifically didn't have I was
watching the thing earlier that said
yeah there was a cartoon where one of
them was like using sausages as
nunchucks and they cut that scene out
because it's like it was still not sure
I didn't say don't do that anymore but
they used to Teenage Mutant hero Turtles
thank you that's what it was I knew that
they had changed the name I thought that
was like really funny
John Gore said interesting fact the
director of Faces of Death went on to
make the Fall Guy
so there you go uh let's see fake animal
cruelty is seen in Dead Alive with the
Stomps the rap back into death yeah we
should we need to do Dead Alive have you
ever seen that oh my God
it's um
it's it's a lot I mean it's like it's a
horror comedy but it's like super super
over the top it's like just [ __ ]
blood and gore and it's like it's
hilarious it's like the Evil Dead But
like a lot more do you know what I mean
just blood everywhere
uh yeah mango says yeah I was gonna talk
about this guy at the time of the Bands
uh James Furman was in charge of the
bbfc I was working in the film industry
at the time if you wanted your movie to
get a lower certificate you could pay a
fee to him and it passed yeah I kind of
feel like there was a lot of that kind
of [ __ ] going on and I think a guy that
was that that same guy or the guy that
came in later that was actually because
I was watching a documentary earlier and
they were talking about one of the guys
that worked at the bbfc who was actually
like um who was actually really into
Cinema and knew a lot of the people like
he knew Ken Russell so they were talking
about the whole
brouhaha about the Devils that Ken
Russell movie that very famously has we
reviewed it like um probably like last
year I think where it very famously has
that kind of like um you know it's based
on a true story but it has that scene
where all those nuns are like
masturbating and you know [ __ ] the
Jesus on the cross kind of thing and
it's they it's funny because they have
all these letters going back and forth
between Ken Russell and the guy at the
bbfc and them like telling them that he
has to like cut all this stuff out and
him like begging them not to take the
stuff out like please take out the nun
you know pretending to masturbate with
the cast with the candle or whatever and
it's just like it's very very funny like
just the way the matter of fact when
they talk about it and like all the
stuff that they're trying to get him to
take out is just like suit I mean it
wasn't funny at the time because he was
really just like please don't cut my
movie To Pieces but I mean I don't know
it was just like really funny but he was
like friends with a guy at the
censorship so they were like a little
bit more lenient they did tend to be
more lenient
on films that were seen as having like
artistic Merit you know what I mean it's
kind of like although I mean they did
come down hard on like um you know silo
120 days of Sodom but those letters were
funny too because like you know the guy
would like write back and be like okay
I've taken out the [ __ ] eating now can
we just like do this and that the other
thing and it's just like oh my God it's
just like [ __ ] hilarious but um like
I said it wasn't funny at the time but
uh yeah Ben says the California
comptroller who shot himself on air yeah
yeah the woman was an anchor woman the
guy was a politician yeah I thought it
was a woman that shot herself like the
news person I thought it was a woman
that shot herself on TV like we were
talking about faces of death like before
um weirdo dude said if that electric
chair dude was fake then he needs an
Academy Award
uh that John Smith said Reefer Madness
oh my God
I [ __ ] love we need to cover Reefer
Madness one of these days too because
that's oh my God that [ __ ] was [ __ ]
hilarious you could tell that whoever
made that movie had never smoked pot
before in their whole entire life I mean
the way that people were acting they
took like one puff off the [ __ ] and then
they started acting like completely
unotics I'm just like yeah that's not
what happens but okay
um let's see Danny Rowling said speaking
of video nasty is the Italian film Night
Train murders takes place on Christmas
making it a Christmas flip flick
technically uh which would be cool to
see reviewed just saying okay well I'll
take that under advisement
and let me see
mrady said did not have to fake car
accident footage drivers were impaled on
the steering column quite frequently I
would imagine that would be very gory
actually my grandmother's brother died
like that when he was a teenager he hit
a pole or a tree and he was impaled on
the steering column
um and then Danny rolling said the best
gore website showed way more horrific
[ __ ] than any video nasty that's the
thing it's like and all
other than you know we've talked about
Cannibal Holocaust yes that had real
animal cruelty and I think some of the
other films you know they kind of got
cut for that too but most of the other
movies they were just they're fake and a
lot of them weren't even really that
good
um and if you watch them now they're
pretty tame
but just you know the fact that they
thought they they had never seen
anything like that yeah you passed a
good uh
where where Richard Brown
look he's talking about Ted Bundy
um I didn't see it hold on
where
oh Ted Bundy blamed pornography but when
they searched his home they found not
one piece of porn yeah
pornography didn't make him go kill
women
I mean if pornography made you kill
people then everybody would be killing
people yeah at least every dude would be
killing people because they all watch
porn I remember somebody commented on
that in on a documentary that I want to
watch about Ted Bundy
and that um they said that
while he was on death row
weight and execution which that took
years a lot of like uh social activists
groups kept approaching him and he would
deal with them and like take up their
causes sometimes
so he could get out of the get out and
get off a death row and like you know
get some candy or something you know and
one of them I think that they said was
that
anti-pornography groups and he was just
saying yeah yeah pornography did I'm
saved you know I'm with Jesus now he was
doing [ __ ] like that
I kind of feel like a lot of them do
that kind of stuff like just to make
themselves they're trying to make
themselves relevant yeah and other
groups want to use them as a puppet but
they get off a death row and they're
able to have a day where they can get
out of the cell and they can uh go do an
interview and maybe see some chick
that'll interview them and they'll get a
sandwich and you know that's what that's
that's why they do that [ __ ] yeah that's
all it is they don't mean any of that
crap well and I do kind of feel like you
know especially serial killers or
multiple murderers and stuff like that a
lot of them go to prison and they'd be
like it's boring I Found Jesus now like
you know parole me you know what I mean
it's that kind of [ __ ] they're just
trying to get something yeah but I
remember them talking about that he
blamed pornography about something but
they didn't have any pornography
um I think there was a big anti-porn
thing going on at the time and he was
just trying to blame other things it
wasn't me it was a porn
you know that's just the kind of [ __ ]
that they would do well back in the old
days they'd say the devil made me do it
yeah but then they back off on all that
[ __ ] you know they're going oh no I was
the best at what I did you know yeah
that uh Green River Killer guy yeah he's
he's a scumbag he's a bottom feeder
that's what he called The Green River
Killer a bottom feeder
yeah I mean
because they didn't caught him they
hadn't caught Ridgeway yet yeah they
were they went to him trying to see if
they could help him and he was just
saying well and uh
Bundy looked at victimology and they
were prostitutes and he goes he's going
after them he's like he's a bottom
feeder he was look at my girls my girls
were all [ __ ] beautiful and
upstanding you know so they they try to
you know they they compete against one
another
they're like you know yeah he's trashy
that guy that's [ __ ] up there's a
highway for Good Girls there's a
hierarchy but yeah serial killers he
said he said it was evidence that he he
was it wasn't hot and that he wasn't
skilled
that he couldn't get a woman's getting a
woman's trust that he had to hunt from
the bottom of the pile
oh Ted you see look Ted saw himself is
awesome he saw himself as awesome
unfortunately nobody else in the world
did
girlfriends he was
[Music]
he was at and then like one of them was
some he had some Ultra fan who was a
lawyer who wanted to marry me she did
marry him didn't she I was on death row
yeah I think yeah that's right yeah
she was kind of women that are attracted
to these guys yeah but like I said those
those ladies have their own issues gonna
say I mean
yeah you got mental problems yeah you
like those guys big time Big they had
this fantasy that they're gonna save
I kind of feel like that's what it is
it's just kind of like this thing I know
there's kind of like an overarching
um
belief that oh women like bad boys which
you know maybe that's true to some
extent but not all women are like that
yeah but I'll live with you that's the
thing it's just like I it's like maybe
so it's like a little bit of that but
then it's like that like taken to like a
horrible horrible extreme maybe that's
all it is like they just think oh he's
the worst of the worst but he loves me
and he wouldn't feel like I'm special
yeah he would never hurt me but like I
said that's messed up like you know what
I mean that's really messed up you
really need some like therapy like if
you think like that it's like pretty bad
that's pretty bad
um let me see this I got really behind
again okay
um yeah mango said that was uh John
treble and that's right that was his
name who was in charge of the bbfc at
the time the Devils he passed the
Exorcist uncut well see that's the thing
is that
what happened I kind of feel like
because when Home Videos started coming
to the four like in the late 70s there
was already like I said they already had
like a thing like the MPAA that would
certify movies for the theater you know
what I mean just like we had they'd give
it a certificate like they call it over
there which is either like you know 15
or 18 or whatever like say what like who
could see it like if kids could see it
or not so they already had that and just
like the MPAA does in the United States
I mean that had been around I think
since 1912 like in the UK
I'm not sure like when the mpa came
around in the in the U.S but it was the
same kind of thing they'd watched movies
and be like oh well you know should we
trim anything out of this or what age
could see this or blah blah blah so they
had that already but the thing about it
was that when home video first came into
you know it was a new technology at the
time and they realized that they didn't
really have any laws covering that you
know what I mean they only had laws
covering like the theater kind of [ __ ]
they didn't have any legislation
specifically for video content the only
thing that they had was a law that had
passed in 1959 which is called the
obscene Publications act which is just
for porn it wasn't for violent movies or
anything like it was just for
pornography like basically just saying
you know you could be prosecuted if you
sold like you know sold [ __ ] to kids or
something like that
um so that's basically all they had
so I think the thing about it was that
they were kind of left scrambling
because there was this Gap and in this
Gap in the market people realized you
know people that made these like low
budget really violent like exploitation
movies realized hey we can just like
release these on videotape and we don't
even have to like give them to anybody
to be certified we don't have to cut
them we don't have to do anything
because there was no law that covered
that for a little while so there was
kind of like a gap in the market because
the technology was new and they hadn't
really thought about it you know what I
mean so for a time you could kind of get
anything like people were just coming up
with all kind of like crazy horrible
[ __ ] like from other countries and stuff
like that because you could release
anything you wanted because it wasn't
playing in a theater
so it didn't have to be rated and you
could like put whatever you wanted in
there
um ironically though what ended up
happening later on was that some movies
you know like the Exorcist or something
like that which had already played in
cinemas and had been passed and we're
fine but then like when they came out on
home video like they had to be like
looked at Anew and then sometimes they
would cut them up because they were like
oh well we shouldn't have passed this or
like it was different people and [ __ ]
like that so like I said it was like
really really arbitrary like the whole
kind of thing
I mean the thing about the obscene
Publications act which like I said I
kind of feel like that was more toward
porn but I guess it was just kind of
like one of those things where who was
it that said like obscenity like or
pornography it's like you can't Define
it like you know it when you see it I
don't know but he's right I kind of feel
like there's some [ __ ] that didn't have
nudity in it and I'm going that's so hot
that's porn
feeling when you see it you know what it
is you know what it is when you see it
yeah well I I don't remember if they
said that specifically about obscenity
or about pornography
but the obscene Publications act in the
UK
basically it defined obscenity as
anything that
um would tend to deprave and corrupt
persons
who are likely
to read see or hear the matter contained
or embodied in it
um you know having regarded to all
relevant circumstances they're basically
like if we if somebody sees it and they
think it's obscene then pretty much it's
obscene I mean that's kind of what it
sounds like what they're saying you know
what I mean and the thing about like a
lot of the movies that ended up on the
video nasties list
some of them I feel like maybe wouldn't
have ended up on there if like one
[ __ ] somewhere didn't like
complain about it
I know porn when I see it but I don't
agree with it that that just because
it's porn it's obscene that's the thing
yeah there's a there's really a big a
Chasm of difference yeah it's a big
[ __ ] difference there's a Chasm of
difference yeah
I mean I do kind of feel like like I
said I'm not saying that you should just
be able to show anything to anybody like
that's dumb you know you shouldn't be
able to make a snuff film I don't think
you should be able to like I don't think
he'd be showing porn to like little kids
or nothing like that but if you're an
adult I I really don't see that you that
you can't watch pretty much like within
reason like watch pretty much whatever
you want I mean you should be able to be
the Arbiter of what you can handle and
what you can't
like I said as long as it's not real and
nobody got like exploited for the [ __ ]
and here's another thing man people said
well these you know got all this
internet man these kids are getting a
hold of porn [ __ ] we were getting a hold
of it when I was [ __ ] eight nine
that's what I mean people have been like
kids have been give us harder back then
but they still did it it went that hard
that's what I'm saying I mean yeah it's
a lot easier nowadays but they were
doing it back then too yeah what's the
problem
she wants she's good this is boring come
on okay
Jeffy art said erotica is very
subjective hence fetish content exactly
yeah that's what I mean it just kind of
seems like you know what's the matter
Pokey what are you complaining about
she's like it's too boring are you are
you upset because we're not paying
attention yeah she's purring
your parents
she's like okay yeah
yeah she wants to throw throw things to
her well you can if you want you can
throw things back yes you gotta do the
show
I can't throw right now she doesn't like
things thrown in here anyway no she
wants me to throw out in the living room
yeah so she can [ __ ] shop up there
and try to grab it
that's the little mice and little toys
just thought
you think the cats are little catching
machines okay that's all they do they
catch machines
John Gore said internet porn is way
crazier than The Playboy's Hustlers and
penthouses I grew up with that's the
thing I caught well I kind of feel like
because it was more expensive I mean
obviously it's more expensive to put out
like a full color like glossy magazine
back then
um so they're gonna try and appeal to as
wide an audience as possible so it's
gonna be kind of like vanilla or kind of
like not all that
exciting or like not all that weird but
the Internet is just it's so free you
can put anything on there pretty much so
it's like you know all bets are off you
can put whatever the [ __ ] you want to on
there and like some somebody will find
it like even in the early 80s we were
getting a hold of [ __ ] Club
International and [ __ ] like that some of
it was like a hardcore porn some of it
was we just got our hands on whatever we
could [ __ ] didn't have that [ __ ]
stashed outside kids were [ __ ]
sharing it [ __ ] I don't know you know
like oh man look somebody's brought a
new stack you know it was it was it was
a different time
yeah and that was like [ __ ] I guess I
was about
between the ages of [ __ ] eight
and maybe [ __ ] 13 10 no 8 and 8 and
12 probably
after that you can get your hands on
[ __ ] porn
you could buy it from your friends at
school
hey look what I got wow was it yeah okay
then you [ __ ] buy it from him or
trade it
yeah
we used to do it back then there's
magazines back then
well the thing about it too is that like
you know jumping off from that
um you know yeah kids were like you know
trading porn in school they were also
trading like drugs well no okay sorry
what I was gonna say was they were you
know getting back to the topic was
horror comics okay horror comics and
horror books because I kind of feel like
the term nasty like in the UK which
later became applied to video nasty was
originally applied to books yeah you
know what I mean like there's kind of
like cheap paperback books that not
necessarily horror but um anything that
had like a lot like real graphic
violence in it or like was Nazi
exploitation or something like that so
kids were always kids love [ __ ] up
[ __ ] they just do I mean I did every kid
I know did so if you had something that
was like salacious or that you weren't
supposed to have whether it was smut or
whether it was horror [ __ ] or whether it
was something that was like way above
like your age then everybody wanted a
piece that everybody wanted to see what
that was I didn't see any drugs in
Middle School got into high school and I
went to two high schools I went to the
same high school with grafters in
Michigan Trenton high and then I went to
uh skoda graduate de Sao Paulo in
[ __ ] Sao Paulo Brazil and I traveled
between the two
like I went back to Brazil from a senior
year and there were drugs in both of
those high schools Trenton
weed LSD and mescaline we had that
Brazil rich people drugs cocaine really
good weed
couldn't get LSD but just mostly cocaine
and wheat
and and we didn't have to worry about
alcohol because alcohol was legal for
for a person in high school in Brazil
I could walk right into a bar or a club
drink or to drink this flicking it was
great
that's where I went down the wrong road
and I was a kid but uh
so
there's no way of controlling anything
you couldn't show anything back then
it's just it's just yeah like I said I
don't think it should be encouraged like
if I had kids
um which I don't but if I had kids I
wouldn't be like here have a beer or
here and watch some porn or you know
watch [ __ ] I don't know like uh I'm
trying to think of like a real [ __ ] up
like horror movie but you know just
watch that it's like I'm not gonna show
my kids that yeah but another thing
that's funny though when you think about
it
parents would have been horrified that
there were drugs in high school back in
the 80s and they would be horrified
today
but we were pretty responsible with them
it's not like it was out of control
you know you knew when you were high
you'd stay out of trouble with your eye
and you know you didn't we didn't do it
every day
it was just sometimes that's the thing
about it it's like in the world because
you could get a joy or get a [ __ ]
a hit of acid it didn't it didn't
most people yeah I mean yeah there's
always going to be people that like get
addicted to it or something like that
but you can kind of rare man that's what
I mean and you can't like just restrict
everybody's access to it just because a
handful of people yeah you know can't
handle it or can't deal with it yeah you
know what I mean so it's just kind of
like you know there's a lot of things
it's just I don't know I I guess I get
offended because I'm a particular I'm
like a big fan of horror and I really
like you know Gore films and stuff like
that so it's just kind of like you know
I don't go around trying to ban like
other people's entertainment that I
don't personally like like I don't like
particular kinds of music or particular
kind of movies but I'm not saying that
other people can't watch them there's a
certain I'm not gonna watch him but it's
like if you want to watch him who cares
there's a certain kind of person and you
pay attention you'll see it today that
are control freaks all right
they have to control your access to [ __ ]
that they don't like you like it but
they don't like it so they don't want
you to have it
you think things that they don't want
you to think so they're trying to get
rid of what you think it's just they
they have people that are just
micromanaging control freaks
and guess what
guess where do you think they gravitate
[ __ ] government and in the legal
system because they're control freaks
my my response to all that is just
ignore them [ __ ] ignore them they're
they're totally
they're full of [ __ ]
just watch your p's and q's do what you
want don't hurt anybody else you'll be
all right Victor says I get internet in
my room in 1995 but I was a freshman in
high school and it made me gay
good resistant man
that's all right
Jungle Booty falling down out of the
ceiling at you [ __ ] ass first just
landed on you you know it wasn't your
fault I'm a big fan of it it was just
just you know it wasn't your fault gay
porn is more interesting to me than
straight porn girl girls like gay porn
that's what they like I mean not all
girls but I like gay porn every girl
ever dated [ __ ] watch gay porn gay
porn and lesbian porn yeah nobody wants
straight porn that's boring yeah they
didn't like that well the thing is is in
most straight porn the guys aren't very
interesting and their the focus is on
the female and [ __ ] it's not so
situational I guess not very artistic
but of course every girl I did well gay
porn gay interracial porn or lesbian
porn I kind of feel well the thing about
a lot of straight pointing this is
obviously like a generalization because
there's tons of different kinds out
there but I kind of feel like straight
porn is more it's since it's more geared
towards straight men
um then it's moratory so like the women
a lot of times don't look like they're
really enjoying themselves because it's
all like for you know it's posed the way
like guys would like and [ __ ] like that
so it's just kind of like I always look
like I always feel like the women don't
look like they're having that good I
love that's corporate [ __ ] you know
Disney [ __ ] Corporation and its
expanse has a lot to do with the [ __ ]
corporate porn I think it was called vac
or Viacom and which is part of Disney
they're behind a lot it's very
um
color by numbers very kind of like mass
production
the best porn is [ __ ] [ __ ] that's
made at home
[ __ ] only fan stuff and stuff that
you know to be made by individual
creators because a lot of the people in
the [ __ ] full-on porn industry are
just burned out that's just a job for
them they don't that's what I mean they
don't like everybody in some ways like
amateur porn I can see why that's a lot
better because it's like these are
people that would be probably having sex
with each other anyway and they just
happen to be like filming it so you
don't get the thing where it's just kind
of like uh yeah yeah it's when it's just
gonna be over some girl with her camera
on her own fans making a custom-made
video for some dude who threw a thousand
dollars at her dropped her a grand and
she makes this [ __ ] video she's like
yeah yeah and it's like the [ __ ] she
likes to do anyway like you never really
see her there's one girl who you never
saw her face you just see her body she
edits and she does herself in public in
weird places and in one place she does
it in a Catholic Church
pretty hot
and full figured chick you know you
never she never shows her face because
she's in public it's in Germany I know
she's German
but that was a that was a long time ago
I guess it's been 10 years now but
that's some of her shit's still classic
for solo scenes legendary
well like in a way that's kind of like
those are kind of I I see that that's
kind of like hotter because that's
somebody just doing what they want to do
nobody's making them do it or you know
they're just doing what they want to do
yeah she got and that's like way more
hot than like just somebody being there
and being like yeah I really wish I
wasn't in this uncomfortable position
and that chick's figure for that body
type it's not 10 out of 10. it's 11 out
of 10.
all right you can find it girl best
debates in church if I can just keep
looking for it you'll find you'll never
see your face you'll just she edits it
out through camera and kids don't care
about girl's faces anyway
she's breaking the law breaking the law
yeah
it was illegal she's doing this well
obviously so that's illegal pretty much
everywhere as far as I know uh John
goris said I remember when teachers used
to frequently brought mad into school
more innocent times I remember in high
school I got sent to the guidance
counselor's office because I was reading
a pet cemetery yeah
my French teacher sent me they thought
that I was like I was like they probably
had no idea what that is well the sea
and that's that's what I was trying to
get back to is that I kind of feel like
these like I said if you see these
[ __ ] that were and they were
essentially like proud of the job they
were doing they thought they were like
you know saving the morals of the nation
or whatever and these are just like
these elderly like Crypt Keeper looking
[ __ ] and they you know and like
yeah and they're like they have no idea
about the history of horror they have no
idea about why people watch that kind of
stuff they just that they don't think of
it as any kind of like artistic
expression they don't think of it like
that to them it's just like trash and
nobody should be watching it if you do
watch it you're like morally depraved
and they like have no idea they just
don't understand like the context behind
it or anything they're saying I'm quite
a bit quieter than you because of the
microphone probably maybe
maybe so Mango's asking for the link uh
if I can find it and I'll [ __ ] point
you down the right direction all right
it's been a long time since I've seen
that one John Smith says they're not on
the nasty list A Clockwork Orange was uh
clandestine too was withdrawn by Kubrick
in the UK due to odd people turning up
at his home yeah I kind of feel like
that's
um
a lot of people misperceive and like the
Wikipedia page I guess is like pretty
good about describing this but a lot of
people misperceive like A Clockwork
Orange as being either like that the UK
government banned it or like that it was
a video nasty it didn't actually work
like that I think as far as I'm aware
I'm pleased if you're in the UK please
correct me if I'm wrong I thought that A
Clockwork Orange passed uncut for
Cinemas
um but then later on Kubrick got death
threats and [ __ ] like that like about
the content of the movie and he chose to
withdraw it so it wasn't so much that he
was forced to withdraw it I believe that
it passed without con without cuts but I
could be wrong I don't know if they cut
out like the rape scenes and stuff like
that because it is like a pretty
unpleasant movie to watch even though
it's one of my favorite movies of all
time but that wasn't that wasn't imposed
on him he did that himself like he just
withdrew it from uh
from because he was like afraid that
something bad was gonna happen because
he got threatened
uh mango said I was always having my
comic books taken off me at Junior
school and it was always the same
teacher Ian England says decriminalize
all substances yeah I agree with you
there
Jeff yard said Jenny seems like the kind
of parent who would introduce her kids
to horror novels or scary ghost stories
oh I totally would I totally would if
they were into it I wouldn't like force
it on them you know what I mean but I
mean if I had a kid and there's other
parents out there like that where you
know they'll be like well what's an
age-appropriate you know movie like you
could start them out like on just like
innocuous [ __ ] like [ __ ] you know
Hocus Pocus and [ __ ] like that
um and then like once they get a little
bit older they could do like Goosebumps
or whatever the [ __ ] or whatever's out
there now like I don't really know I'm
talking about like for my own generation
but I mean I watched a lot of like scary
[ __ ] when I was a kid and you know that
wasn't too scary but I you know I turned
out okay I started like watching
probably slasher movies and like more
horror movies probably earlier than most
people would imagine like you know what
I mean I started like seven or eight or
nine but and they were scary but you
know it didn't traumatize me for life or
anything like that like I said I turned
out like a well-adjusted human being so
you know and I assume they say most most
people yeah yeah I don't know how well
adjusted I think I'm kind of well
adjusted and I mean relatively but you
know what I mean
you know what I mean
um yeah American Military 100 said I
think the Traces of Death franchise with
much grizzlier than Faces of Death yeah
I remember hearing about that like we
kind of thought of it as like the
knockoff but I don't even remember if I
ever saw those I saw like a bunch of the
Faces of Death ones but I don't think I
saw any of the Traces of Death one
um let's see yeah send me the link yeah
I'm trying to find it but I'm having
connection problems Victor says I've
never seen A Clockwork Orange what
oh
man A Clockwork Orange is a great film
the book is good too although it's
the book is harder to get through
because you know I don't probably you
know but it's in uh like a slang like a
made-up slang
it's called natsat
in the movie it's a lot easier to parse
because you know you have the context
you could see what's happening in front
of you so it's not like so weird and
they do actually have like regular
English and stuff in there too but the
book is a lot the book has to have a
glossary in the back I love the book
also but
um the movie's great though the movie's
great I can see why it was controversial
I mean some stuff about it is probably
still controversial nowadays I feel well
maybe not as much as it was back then
but
it's crazy like seeing it now
because remember we were talking about
the Ken Russell movie the the Devils
because we just reviewed that not too
long ago and that movie I think if you
made that now
like the same with all the same content
and I think people would still freak out
about it now like a certain segment
would freak out about it because it is
very Blasphemous and I was actually like
really and I don't even I don't believe
in that kind of stuff like I don't
believe in blasphemy I don't believe
that's a thing but you know people would
get offended by it I think people would
be very offended by that nowadays still
and the fact that they made that back in
the [ __ ] 70s that's that blows my
mind a little bit
uh mr88 said A Clockwork Orange is the
only Kubrick film I like you don't like
The Shining interesting
Danny Rowling said what's Tom and
Jenny's favorite video nasty film and
why
whoo
all right I'm gonna refer to my list of
all of the movies because I haven't seen
all of them I do kind of want to do a
thing where I watch all of them
but I'm gonna say Okay so the best ones
out of the section one ones I think uh a
bay of blood the Mario Bava one
I really like that a lot and actually if
you haven't seen that if you're into
slasher movies you have to see that
because that is almost like the
Prototype of like the slasher movies and
I know a lot of people think that like
Halloween the John Carpenter was like oh
the first Lasher movie that was the
first one that popularized that but a
bay of blood is almost like watching
Friday the 13th except like a long time
before Friday the 13th you know what I
mean like Friday the 13th Part Two even
ripped off a couple of gags from a bay
of blood so there's that
um you know that was 1972 that came out
I think or maybe even earlier might have
been 68 no maybe it was 72 I can't
remember it was before black Christmas
too because I know black Christmas gets
uh called up a lot too as being
uh you know kind of one of the early
slasher movies
um driller killer Abel Ferrara that's a
good one too um that's another one that
I've been wanting to review that one got
in big trouble because bless you sweetie
um because the cover of that one
actually showed like a drill like going
into the dude's forehead you know what I
mean and they slapped that right on the
[ __ ] cover and everybody's like oh no
can't have that but that's actually like
a decent movie it's honestly I haven't
seen it a long time but I remember it
being kind of more like it's not really
a slasher movie it's kind of more like a
sleazy Thriller
I like Abel ferreira's movies like um
miss 45 is probably my favorite of his
but
uh evil speak was on the sick which is
that's a good flick I liked it I don't
really know
because this says um because they had a
they have a list um and they kind of
tell you like how much you know like
what list it was put on initially and
like how much was cut out of it and blah
blah evil speak it says it was released
with in 1987 with three minutes and 34
seconds cut out of it but was
re-released uncut in 2004 and I'm having
a hard time evil speaks seemed very mild
to me I haven't seen it in a while
admittedly we've reviewed it
I don't remember it a couple years ago
maybe
what would they have taken out three
minutes that's a long time
what was in there that that would have
been taken out I can't think of a single
thing like some of these I can I
remember like that there were scenes and
I'm like oh yeah I can see they probably
would have taken that out uh flesh for
Frankenstein
uh that had uh they actually passed it
for the cinema with a couple little
things cut out but they cut out like a
minute of it like in 96 but released it
uncut later the weird thing about that
is that you know the Andy Warhol that's
the Andy Warhols Frankenstein they call
it even though Paul Morrissey directed
it but it's weird because that is on the
video nasties list but Andy warhol's
Dracula which I kind of feel like in
some ways is like worse as far as like
maybe not Gore but at least like the
concept concept behind it they passed
that without any Cuts or they pass or
that wasn't like prosecuted ever so like
I said it was like very very arbitrary
there's a really famous story too where
when they were first
because what initially happened like I
said when it was just this kind of wild
west where they didn't really have a law
because now everybody's like releasing
all these videotapes and they didn't
have a law like saying that they had to
be
um you know certified like for any so
anybody could just rent them
so they had this thing and then they
were coming up with all this arbitrary
rules and they were very local so they
kind of left it in the hands of like
local constabularies so like sometimes
cops would come in and they'd seizes oh
it's like that looks like a Gore movie
or that looks like a porno and they
would seize it that you know they'd like
take it out of your store and then it
would turn out later like there was a
one famous case where
um I can't remember what city it
happened in but like they came in and
they seized uh The Best Little
Whorehouse in Texas because they thought
it was a porno movie it's a musical with
[ __ ] Dolly Parton and Burt Reynolds
in it we reviewed it not too long ago
yeah there's no it's not even spotty I
don't even is there even boobs in it no
I don't even think there's boobs in it
uh no I don't think there is I don't
even think there's boobs in it but it's
like they just went by the title yeah so
the reason that the the whole video
nasties list came about in the first
place was because people that owned
video shops were like well you you know
if you have these cops just arbitrarily
coming to like seizing [ __ ] off the
shelves we don't know what we're allowed
to sell and what we're not it's like you
know what I mean like can you please
just give us a list of like [ __ ] we're
not allowed to sell and we'll help you
out and so that's when they came up with
this list and then like it kind of
became more codified later on as they
actually watched the [ __ ] and all this
other kind of stuff
but
um house by the cemetery is Lucio fulchi
That's a classic uh you know that's on
that was on the list as well uh they cut
four minutes out of that when they
released it on video in 80 1988 but uh
it was later released uncut in 2009 uh I
mentioned I Spit on Your Grave earlier
which it's not a pleasant movie to watch
like I said but I always I don't know
like I just have some kind of like weird
affection for that film I especially
like the
I especially like the scene where she
cuts that tooth stick off in the in the
bathtub because I like that he just like
doesn't
uh realize it for a second I don't know
why that makes me laugh so hard but it
does but yeah that's it's a really
unpleasant movie to watch the rape
Revenge that's a whole sub-genre
but well the weird thing and like I made
this argument like I wrote a thing not
too long ago and I made the argument
where I was like You could argue that a
movie like Deliverance Deliverance is a
rape Revenge movie right I mean there's
other things going on too but it's a
rape Revenge movie essentially Ned
Beatty gets raped and and his friends
like fight back like against the dudes
that did it I Spit on Your Grave is also
a rape Revenge movie I mean she's out at
the cabin she's a writer like all of
these like yokels come and gang rape her
and then she systematically goes and
kills them all like some of them cutting
their dicks off first which you know
fair enough
so I don't understand like why
Deliverance is okay but I spit in your
grave isn't okay you know what I mean
because it's essentially the same story
I think
um so I I don't know I don't know I
don't know I don't know why one's
allowed and not the other one's not
allowed like I said they did seem to
give like some leeway to movies that
were more like that were from more
respected filmmakers as I said now
somebody like Ken Russell yeah he got
some [ __ ] for like the devils and stuff
but the Devils I mean is a pretty
even by today's standards is pretty out
there like you wouldn't you'd have a
hard time nowadays showing a movie that
had like groups and of nuns like [ __ ]
a statue of Jesus okay like people would
still have a hard time with that
nowadays but
I don't know like it just seems like
I don't know I don't understand like
what the whole what the whole [ __ ] was
and then and the thing about it like I
said I was talking earlier about like
sallow 100 days 120 days of Sodom which
had a lot of cuts but they seemed like
they were more willing to give that one
some leeway because the dude was trying
to make a point you know what I'm saying
yeah so they thought oh well it had
artistic Merit even though they did tell
him it's like can we please take out the
[ __ ] eating and all that kind of stuff
although you can see it uncut nowadays
although I don't want to watch that I've
watched it once and I was just saying
okay okay
um
mango I was trying to find the original
post
I found one of them all right uh there
isn't any I can say the bathroom yeah I
can say it
go on xHamster
all right and just go goddess
masturbates
again in a church
she's made several of them and it will
come up but that's not the original post
all right you can't see anything there
but that that's it and uh she's got like
two or three like that
it
I remember when the original came it's
it's it's a it's it's an amateur
and she was making money
out of a German
out of a German site kind of like their
version of uh of only fans that's where
it came from
uh
a couple year you know it gets about
five six years ago there was she
probably had about 20 videos
but that chick there man
[ __ ] a trip
um
there's another one on there just says
risky masturbation
also not an original post but on that
you'll be able to find out where it came
from originally I'm sure she's still
around
but that's not the original that's just
what I can find right now
Jenny about ready to come back
but that was she was the church girl
good old church girl
okay
you're not even talking I don't have to
what do you mean you don't have to
because I'm
just got a message from Mary Lynn
thank you mango thanks very much the
bbfc and Furman hated folgy they pretty
much banned all his movies yeah I think
they banned all his movies and I think
if you had um cannibal in the title of
your movie they just automatic they
didn't even watch that [ __ ] they were
just like yep nope not allowed not
allowed
um Ben says uh an Australian writer got
raided by the cops in the 80s for
something and They seized his VHS tapes
marked as the young ones convinced
they'd busted a CP operation
ah see that's what I mean you can't
really have people that don't know jack
[ __ ] about horror
regulating horror films they don't know
what they're looking at you know what
I'm saying and it's just kind of like I
was reading this article earlier and
like the guy I'm kind of like
paraphrasing I think it was um Kim
Newman that wrote it actually but I
could be wrong about that but um you
know he's kind of a famous like uh
horror guy and he was saying you know
it's very very it's an easy moral stance
to take to condemn [ __ ] that you don't
care about or that you don't know
anything about and I kind of feel like
that very succinctly like summed up this
whole era as I said they were obviously
trying to scapegoat it's an easy thing
to scapegoat I mean it's [ __ ] that kids
like or people that you know are seen as
like degenerates or weirdos like
particularly back then like if you were
into horror like people thought you
there was something that mattered with
you so you know it was a really easy
thing to blame you know well obviously
these kids are messed up or rioting or
whatever it is they're doing because
they saw this movie where somebody got
their head cut off and it's all that
other kind of stuff it's just like an
easy thing to blame because it's it's
simpler people like Simple Solutions
they don't really like
the reality that [ __ ] is a lot more
complicated
you know and and things have like a lot
more complicated
uh you know reasons then
than normal Okay so
oh slasher Fred said at the end of
Deliverance the dream sequence where the
hand Rises uh inspired many movies like
Carrie or Friday the 13th yeah I feel
like that was like a big thing Ben said
spoilers I don't know what I said that
was spoilered
what about I Spit on Your Grave did she
cut the dude's dick off make you no
drink yeah Ben says these pornographers
need Jesus here's the thing and I'm
again this is a generalization this is
just this is anecdotal
um just from my experience
what I have found in my 50 years on
Earth
is that people who are really into
horror movies like they're really into
you know all that kind of stuff like
they go to conventions and stuff like
that 99 of those people are the [ __ ]
nicest people you will ever meet in your
whole entire life my uh theory about
that is that they get their Darkness out
by watching fake [ __ ] like they enjoy
fake [ __ ] like I definitely like get
you know kind of the thing so I don't
have to be like a [ __ ] I don't have
to be like you know dark in real life
because you watch all this stuff like
that so most people I was like 99 of
people that I've ever met that were
super super into horrible like the
nicest people ever
conversely uh people who are really
really uptight who really really don't
like horror who are really like condemn
people who like horror who try to be
really morally upstanding about you know
I you know I go to church and I'll do
this without the other 99 of those
people are terrible horrible people who
have skeletons in their closet big time
this is like I said it's not true across
the board this is just my experience
because they have [ __ ] to hide I kind of
feel like people that are into horror
they're just like wearing that [ __ ] on
their sleeve like letting their freak
flag fly and so they don't have anything
to hide they're not trying to be
anything that they're not whereas people
who are trying to appear normal or
upstanding or you know super religious
or whatever
um I always like distrust people like
that because I'm like well what are you
trying to cover up then like why can't
you just be a regular ass person you
know and just like what you like so you
know and I'm not saying across the board
like I said because I've met some like
super super religious people super super
conservative people that were lovely
lovely people but in general
um you know if they're real weird about
people liking horror and stuff like that
they've got some [ __ ] going on you know
and it's probably bad like probably way
worse than anything that I could think
of you know
uh Mega said yep just like the nuns and
the Devils yeah
because the more you repress that kind
of [ __ ] the more it's going to come out
in real freaky ways real freaky so
if you just admit that you know yeah I
got some like [ __ ] up thoughts or
[ __ ] up ideas but it's like as long as
I don't act like it's okay and if you
have like an outlet for dealing with
that then you're gonna be a lot better
like nicer more well-adjusted person
than somebody that's trying to portray
themselves in a specific way and they're
not that specific way you know what I'm
saying so I kind of feel like that
that's my whole thing about it and that
was the main problem as I said that I
had I'm not saying that like all the
people
um you know that were on the board of
sensors I'm sure most of them were like
just fine but
I just didn't like the way that they
came at it that they came at it that you
know we can watch these movies and it's
like oh we're outraged and we're
horrified by all of this kind of stuff
but they didn't really seem like they
tried to understand
why anybody would want to watch that or
why anybody would want to enjoy that
because they didn't enjoy it and they
really seemed like they couldn't
put themselves into someone else's shoes
and understand like why somebody else
might like to watch that kind of thing
yeah like they couldn't yeah they
couldn't
so it's like a lack of empathy in some
ways they're like oh well I'm this way
so everyone else should be this way and
I've known a lot of people like that
yeah I can't imagine it's like I
wouldn't want everybody to be like me
for home God forbid you know what I mean
it's just like I wouldn't wish that on
anybody but uh you know what I mean it's
just kind of like look I'm super into
like [ __ ] horror movies and punk rock
and [ __ ] like that but I don't think
other people should be into that so if
you don't like it that's cool like we
can still hang out we can still talk and
everything like that as long as you
don't get all [ __ ] up in my grill
about oh I shouldn't like this that and
the other thing I think that's why I was
so mad it's a lot better now
um because most people are just kind of
like yeah okay whatever like like what
you like especially since the Advent of
the internet and you can like find
whatever you want so you can find your
own people and you can find your Niche
and stuff so I think that's a lot better
but like when I was growing up
especially being a girl I do kind of
feel like in the 80s like um it was
weirder like for a girl to be into
horror especially I mean where I grew up
I don't know if it was like that in
other places but where I grew up like
people they didn't really like that boys
were into horror they thought you were
oh you were going to be a serial killer
but they especially thought it was
strange if you were if you were a girl
they thought you were just like [ __ ]
Satan incarnate
John Smith said yep uptight people are
repressing a lot of stuff Grindr goes
through the roof whenever Republicans
have conventions it does it's like
that's what I mean it's like they're
trying to portray a certain
uh facade and you know that there's [ __ ]
going on behind that it's just like just
be for just be a freak it's fine it's
like everyone's fine with it nowadays
you don't have to like hide anything you
don't have to like pretend to be
something you're not as long as you're
not hurting anybody as long as
everyone's consenting just be into what
you're into it's fine be a furry be
whatever it's like it's fine nobody
cares just
don't try to be a specific thing don't
try to like be normal don't there's no
such thing no such thing
um one of these days you should watch if
I can go ahead and counter that though
there is normal the normal is basic as
[ __ ]
there's a lot of that going on at the
biker bar up there you know they're cool
and everything but they're just at a
certain
cultural place but I understand it
though you know what I mean but they're
within a certain bandwidth and that's it
very few of them are going to step
outside that bandwidth yeah I get that I
mean I I kind of like dealt with that a
lot to you because I grew up in a very
biker or a red hockey kind of and out of
you yeah and I would consider I would
consider them actually like normal
real they don't consider themselves
normal they think they're [ __ ] they
think they're crazy real crazy but I'm
like no man you're mundane but you know
you're cool but you that you know you
it's it's a very kind of like
um rural Farm
uh uh it's kind of like the dark side of
the [ __ ] rural country yeah mentality
but it's not they're not that weird
though they're not that weird they're
into office they think they're weird but
they're not but they're just real
[ __ ] basic basic mundane tastes you
know I don't even know what I would
consider weird like and I'm not talking
about just weird and like you know
obviously if you're a [ __ ] serial
killer so like that's bad that's not
weird that's [ __ ] up get out of the
get out of the human race yeah but other
than that like I'm not really sure what
I consider weird like if I was talking
to somebody and they said hey I'm really
into like some bizarre ass thing I'd be
like all right as long as it wasn't like
hurting anybody like what it's none of
my business you know what I mean it's
just I don't understand like why people
get upset about what other people are
doing in their own houses
as long as they're not hurting anybody
as long as everybody's an adult and
everyone's consenting I was like you can
do whatever the [ __ ] you want get you
like I said get your freak on
it doesn't affect me in this latest it
doesn't affect me yeah it's like some of
the [ __ ] you I hear younger people
[ __ ] complaining about on YouTube a
day about identity and gender identity
and [ __ ] like that to me that's all
[ __ ]
kinda
faux Posh you know what I mean that's
kind of like what just do what you want
to do why are you why are you making a
big deal the thing about it I think what
that is is because we're kind of used to
like I said we grew up in the god scene
a lot of people didn't yeah and so I
kind of feel like for us it's not as big
a deal but for them yeah it's a bigger
deal big deal for you that well it was a
bigger deal and well the thing about it
is like for a long time like the
mainstream culture yeah was not
accepting of that yeah so I think it's
you know I think it's they're they're
kind of coming to thinkable it's like oh
it's okay now so they can come out and
talk about it like for us it's kind of
like old that was like 30 years ago well
for us it's old hat but like I said the
mainstream like if you'd come out look
you know and some people here might
might know because like some people here
as old as us I mean if you came out as
gay like back then like in my high
school you'd have got your ass beat and
I knew a guy that got his ass beat for
that very reason
High School's kind of [ __ ] up anyway
well yeah but it's I mean it's [ __ ] up
for everybody I'm just saying that it's
like well and actually I knew a straight
guy that got his ass beat for wearing
eyeliner it depends on where it works it
bends out where you were me and grafters
[ __ ] High School Trenton high in
Michigan it was very
middle class upper middle class working
classes it was just like something out
of them back to the future like the high
school the [ __ ] Marty McFly went to
you know it just
it was a good school
it's the way most American schools
should be but it's kind of generic in a
way but in a good way it was kind of a
universal we had gays there nobody
[ __ ] with them
you know it I could see how maybe in the
Bible Belt maybe well like I said I grew
up in a really good I grew up in a real
redness
but so if you looked a little bit weird
yeah you were gonna use your assby but
most of America I don't think I think
most of America was kind of like in the
high school closer to what me and
grampers were in we had gays we had
lesbians nobody gave us [ __ ]
they weren't and they were kind of out
you could tell lesbian girls you know
who the lesbians were you know who the
gay dudes were
nobody really cared
not not that not well in a way you were
kind of like lucky because it's not
where I was I didn't really have those
prejudices no you know uh and I did I
wasn't around a bunch of people most
most of America really wasn't like that
the south is different it's very
different especially if you start
talking about areas where there were a
lot of poverty
they're [ __ ] tough and they're
conformist as [ __ ] yeah well that's kind
of what I was dealing with real
conformist you were seriously if you
were like regular clothes in the 80s you
could wear regular clothes if you have
black nail polish on everybody freaked
out yeah and what was weird is that what
she's describing is more conformist than
what was going on say like in Heidelberg
and Laurel Mississippi because the
population density wasn't high enough to
have conformity
so it's very different than what she's
talking about uh you know uh the high
school kids in Laurel Mississippi
listened to the [ __ ] Violent Femmes
and [ __ ] cool New Wave Music and [ __ ]
like that there wasn't and they and and
early cure that was real calm see I knew
like 10 people that ran into that and
and we were the weirdos right and one of
those one of those people was Parker
Posey you guys know her as Parker Posey
she's uh she was in Blade three she's a
friend of mine it's from uh Laurel
Mississippi
she grew up there but her family wasn't
from there she came from a Yankee family
her dad owned Chris Posey Chevrolet who
was downtown Laurel and she listened to
the Cure and Violent Femmes and [ __ ]
Joy Division and and we were this is
high school era we you know this is
before they all went off to college and
everything and we were having [ __ ]
fun man and they were golf kids in
Laurel Mississippi tiny tiny and the uh
their parents were all upper middle
class
you had rednecks and [ __ ] but you they
just weren't around you didn't ever see
them and uh pretty much all I thought
was yeah and they wouldn't they were
really wouldn't pick on that crowd
because they didn't have the money to
their parents all worked for their
parents so
and it wasn't it wasn't real
um
uh
Mississippi like I said didn't have
enough population density for anybody to
make anything my my first wife was from
Gulfport and I can show you I'll show
her to you she was got this [ __ ] I was
coming I left Boston
uh [ __ ] the man race scene which is
like one of the best golf clubs in the
United States at that time
and I I met Tiff and
um Tiff would have blown anybody in New
York away
or even Boston in a way that and she was
from [ __ ] Gulfport
and it was just because [ __ ] there
weren't enough people to make anybody
conform to anything in in Mississippi
[Laughter]
[ __ ] where is that John Gore said uh
juvenile delinquents are drawn to
certain media but they're juvenile
delinquents first yeah I think that's
another thing and I think you know
getting back to the video nasties thing
is I think one of the things and this
was a little bit of a later iteration
this was like more late 80s early 90s
but there was the whole James Bulger
thing which um you know we did a I think
we did a show about that like those two
little boys that led that other little
boy like often and then like killed him
with a rock or whatever and they got
that whole thing got associated with
Child's Play Three as though that movie
had like made those little boys do that
like they made like a huge deal about
that so Child's Play Three which is like
not even that
um you know that
graphic of a movie or anything but it
got kind of tied to that crime
you know for all that that was
Mississippi in the 90s just out in the
middle of nowhere that girl
that was Michelle though
so you just it's just not
stereo you can't really
stereotypes don't really hold up in
certain areas of the United States you
know
but that's Mississippi of all places
that's Tiff right there
so it's just you know
it all depends on where I guess you grew
up but Daytona had a higher population
so they were making you be a certain way
yeah and if you were like just even a
little bit different because I didn't I
mean I didn't think like from my point
of view I didn't think I looked that
weird but I guess like from their point
of view we would walk around all gossed
out [ __ ] and [ __ ] out in the
middle of nowhere in Mississippi people
hey wow you know people would just trip
out
I get more [ __ ] in Boston
and like I said all I was I mean
okay I'll admit like in high school
um you know yeah I had uh army boots
yeah I had like uh a dollar trench coat
that I got from the thrift store and I
just wore like band shirts and [ __ ] like
that and yeah I had half my head shaved
all right but uh you know I admit it but
but that's the thing it's like to me
that didn't look that weird it's like it
wasn't as weird as I would have liked to
look maybe but it's like you still even
when I was like in junior high like when
you first started doing like it's like
oh I'm gonna color in my um my nails
with like a black marker because it was
harder to get black nail polish back
then you had to wait till Halloween and
then you had to stock up
um because they didn't sell it all year
so you would color them in with a black
marker to be like ew what are you doing
what is that like why what is this tape
that you're listening to who's the Cure
like who's that it was like that you
know what I mean which
is crazy to think about nowadays because
now like every [ __ ] basic [ __ ] in
the world is like out there dancing to
the Cure like when they play him at the
club well it's funny that they were
doing that what year was that
well junior high was mid to late 80s
well okay well high school was 88 89.
okay so it's early all right that's tips
that was my high school that was Tiff's
High School uh High one of her High
School shots that's around
94.
so that was later then it was later okay
now that would have been Mississippi I
graduated in 1990. Mississippi 94. you
had girls like that in a high school
photo shoot
but see that's the thing though because
after 1991 yeah that was what did they
call that the year Punk broke yeah that
was after Nirvana that was after the big
alternative music grunge kind of thing
where suddenly it was like cool to be
alternative like in the 90s prior to
that like I said I graduated from high
school in 1990 so that was before that
happened
um prior to that like if you were into
like weird [ __ ] like nobody knew what
that was
really
not at least not where I lived
they didn't know where that was yeah
he's trying to give me until the [ __ ]
story about the girls jerking off the
horse or pretending again
why you want me to tell that story
what that was California
well that was just like that porno we
saw right no or no you're talking about
he's talking about her name was Debbie
McLeod I believe it was Debbie MacLeod
was her name my third
something rather McLeod was her last
name it was one of my mom's friends this
is back in the late 70s at the [ __ ]
stable
she was sitting there with a cigarette
in her [ __ ] mouth washing her horse
this is all horse girls
and there's some teenage girls were
walking by and they were all they were
drinking too they were drinking
prototype wine coolers I remember them
and the [ __ ]
her horse who was gelded it wasn't a
stallion it was gilded it [ __ ] popped
a boater and she grabbed that [ __ ] was
shaking it at her friends as they were
walking by and they were all [ __ ]
laughing that's what that's what he's
talking about
so that's not really I mean that's not
like really that like that porno that we
saw with the with the girl and the dog
no that was just kind of like you were
just doing it to [ __ ] around yeah she
was doing her photo she was washing the
horse it was right it was in the
bathroom it was in The Wash Rack there's
a flick thing yeah yeah it was in The
Wash Rack and the [ __ ] she was down
there and she was she was cleaning the
the Sheep
on the horse you know [ __ ] sprayed it
because you know they're
Dick's got to come out and there's
[ __ ] crust in there and they gotta
[ __ ] pull out dead skin and [ __ ] she
was cleaning the [ __ ] horses yeah
dick crust and [ __ ] you heard it here
you're not circumcised you know and uh
horse [ __ ] rocked up and [ __ ] and
she's going hey look at this [ __ ] look
at this [ __ ] she's calling her teenage
friends you know she was probably about
22.
under all these 1678 because imagine
that [ __ ] you know what I made it I was
just I was [ __ ] blown away I was
embarrassed as hell you would probably
die I was embarrassed to hell I was
probably like eight or nine when I saw
that
and and but for something for some
reason I thought she was intensely sexy
with that [ __ ] thing
yeah it was about eight or nine I was
like that might be a fetish time it must
be I don't know I was just like girls
with horses I was just [ __ ] totally
blown away I couldn't believe it I was
seeing well maybe it's only male in the
area I was eight so they were blowing me
off like I wasn't there eight or nine
and I was just well just maybe maybe
maybe you didn't realize that like girls
would actually do so yeah [ __ ] like that
yeah yeah yeah like to like [ __ ] with
each other yeah imagine that [ __ ] girls
are gross too yeah yeah she was trying
to get a cigarette hanging out of her
mouth
imagine them [ __ ] laughing and [ __ ]
she's like [ __ ] wagging that [ __ ]
[ __ ] smacking it it's [ __ ] funny
you know horse girls man they're [ __ ]
crazy
I thought you said all girls were crazy
no horse girls
I've had these girls [ __ ] friend me
on here from the show and they're
looking they got pictures of them and
they're [ __ ] equestrian horses
they're all English equestrian writers
because you know my family came from
that background my mother's a pretty
famous trainer and all that
she was a California State national
state champion for like 78 I think in
[ __ ] equitation and she wasn't
jumping but she was in equitation she
went she she was a champion for that
year if I remember correctly either that
was the runner-up I think champion
so uh and she wrote a bunch of books on
it as she got older and I grew up in the
horse industry off and on I mean I go
back to [ __ ] horse bars in this area
if I can I manage the barn for about
[ __ ] two years huh that's I think we
knew each other when that was and Alicia
is living with me at that time yeah I
mean I think I knew you then like I
don't know how long he's been before we
were a day yeah me and Elena were living
together yeah but
and at the bar and I ran that bar
and um now when the clients girls that
like horses and [ __ ] are [ __ ] nuts
well that not in a bad way most of them
are all right that they just they have
certain things about them
and uh
they have money and they're crazy
they're boy crazy too
well okay yeah they are
uh let's see okay so mango says uh this
is something I said a long time ago uh
you're right Jenny I have friends who
are die-hard horror fans like me and
they're very nice even though we may not
agree on politics and other things
horror brings us together yeah honestly
like I said I can't really think of that
many people that I've met that are super
super into horror like Geeks about
horror and stuff most of these people
are super super nice
because as I said you're wearing your
Darkness you're wearing your weirdness
like for everybody to see you're not
trying to hide anything you're not
trying to be something you're not so you
don't have that like the insecurity of
oh like they're gonna find out when I'm
really like or that I'm really weird or
something like that you're like yeah I'm
weird deal with it you know and that
tends to like make you like more chill
uh and Mr 88 said genuinely good people
do not have to advertise yeah the second
you start coming out and being like I'm
such an awesome person I'm such a nice
person I'm like yeah probably not yeah
like if you really were
you wouldn't have to say that you would
have to say that like everybody would
just know and people would other people
would say yeah the woman in church
[ __ ] standing up screaming about how
harsh everybody is she's the [ __ ]
exactly that's what I'm saying yeah and
honestly this is one thing I remember
like growing up in Florida I remember
this one guy this is probably like in
the late 80s because I was
absurdly like weirdly morbidly
fascinated by like televangelists and
like all these like weird fundamentalist
Christian kind of things that were going
on at the time because like I said it
was still very much satanic Panic era
which I thought was like kind of
horrifying and hilarious at the same
time
and there was this one guy he was some
kind of legislator in Florida what the
[ __ ] I can't remember like what his
exact position was I think it's what was
his name Tanner John Tanner something
like that and his big Crusade was
pornography and that was not just like
child porn which yeah you know don't do
child porn obviously but it was just
pornography in general and I was like
that dude's gonna get busted with like
the world's biggest pornography because
nobody cares that much about just like
regular ass porn than somebody that's
like trying to like front you know what
I'm saying why do you care that much
about it well it's just kind of like all
of the like I don't know like any kind
of politician that comes out and like
talks about it's like oh these like you
know trans people are gonna be like
coming in the bathrooms and blah blah
I'm just like um yeah that's somebody is
like way too worried about some [ __ ] and
like may have might have some issues
that they need to address because nobody
in their right mind cares that much
about other people's sexuality if you do
then you might need to do some
self-examination yeah and it's just kind
of the same kind of thing as people that
say I watched a horror movie and you
know I it's like all depraved and blah
blah I'm like maybe you need to like
examine why you felt that way watching
it because most people don't most people
are just seeing it as entertainment or
watching it as like a piece of art or
something going oh look at those cool
like special effects or something like
that it's like nobody is like oh now it
wants to make me be a serial killer if
if it does then you have problems other
problems it's not the movie's fault it's
you yeah it's you just you know just
telling you
um but yeah uh so where was I I don't
know like I I'm talking about like all
these notes because like I said I'm kind
of going to we're kind of talking about
the [ __ ] uh slasher Fred said one of
these days you should watch and review
the 1977 underrated Classic the car we
have reviewed that uh we did a double
feature
I believe it was the car and was it race
with the Devil it was another like
vehicular horror movie I'm pretty sure
it was race with the devil but I think
we did that as a double feature and it
was probably
I want to say it was like a year and a
half two years ago but it might have
been longer because uh you know time
doesn't mean anything to me anymore
somebody asked to see a high school
picture of me oh so
I got long hair and short hair
American Military 100 said can each of
you show a picture of yourselves from
high school I don't have you know what I
don't have one available but um I could
find one and maybe I'll do it arrange it
I'll I'll do it on the if I remember
actually I'll write it down yeah I'll do
it on the Friday Night Show because I
don't have one like at the moment but
I don't think I have any on my Facebook
either I might have some that are like
hidden
that's me probably about 16. this is
Rick Springfield yeah with my Rick's 15
16 around that time that's high school
did you wish you had Jesse's Girl man I
did have Jesse's Girl and the mom
uh okay
mango says race with the Devil is great
yeah it is great and was not banned in
the UK
that's me as a senior
come on you just look all white yeah
yeah there you go
Adriana said uh New Orleans for some
reason when I was a preteen and teen
seemed like the goth capital of the
United States yeah I think that was
mostly Anne Rice's fault yeah we um
living in Mississippi that's where we
partied every weekend [ __ ] doubt
French Quarter go to [ __ ] uh the
[ __ ] hellfire club and uh the crystal
uh that's back when Pierre had the
hellfire club Danny Rowling said looking
like Uncle Jesse from Full House yeah
that too yeah that too yeah um the thing
is is that most guys didn't live there
me my ex-wife and our friends we lived
there we were regulars everybody else
were tourists they were only there for
like the weekend so you'd see Goths from
all over the [ __ ] world
we'll come through there and um they'd
have [ __ ] convergence there and
everything but the thing is like I said
it was a capital but they didn't live
there they just would come visit
it was tourist town
so he says your high school photo you
look like you could be one today's boys
boy bands yeah crowd screaming after you
yeah yeah
a little handsome [ __ ] yeah I
was [ __ ] pretty yeah
it's pretty feathered hair yeah that was
a lot of dudes had that hair though yeah
that was actually kind of Gothic for uh
Andrew Eldritch had that haircut too he
did Andrew Elder's hair for your Sisters
of Mercy yeah which nowadays that's a
mullet yeah but but that's what Andrew
had a lot of new wave like bands had
that we didn't call it a mullet back
then it didn't become a rednecky thing
until later I think yeah I don't
remember it really being a rednecky
thing until maybe the 90s yeah is that
right I mean it's been a while 90s it
became a mullet yeah and then it was
like a rednecky thing like [ __ ] Joe
Dirt and stuff but probably like they
were behind in the fashion by a decade
or so I think that's what happened I
think like they only just caught up with
like a new wave Trend like yeah 10 15
years later like after it had already
like passed by the time the 90s rolled
around short hair was it was in for
dudes
for the most part and if you had long
hair you had parts of it that were
shaved out so it was a mixture well I
kind of feel like well the 90s too
because they had the whole grunge thing
um and they had like the whole like
metal thing you could have like well you
could have like just like straight long
hair like this dreads you could have
that or dreads yeah that was big too I
remember even Billy Idol took uh got
dreads I remember that in terms of the
cyberpunk album white people dreads yeah
yeah I remember that being a bit of a
thing I remember that being a bit of
thing
so yeah so where was I like I said I'm
just kind of like like I said I'm just
kind of like hopping all over because
this is kind of like a broad topic but
uh okay so as I mentioned the only law
that they had regulating stuff they did
have like a they already had like a not
necessarily A censorship arm but it was
kind of like the MPAA they would like
give they'd be like well if you cut this
and that you'll get this certain rating
so they had that that had been around
since night like 1912. but because they
didn't have a law you know about video
tape uh you know there was like a few
years where kind of pretty much anything
went in for a while anything did and for
a few years like [ __ ] just kind of went
under the radar because
you know no one like really thought to
get all that upset about it and no and
it hadn't really like seeped into the
public Consciousness I feel like
so nobody had a freak out about it until
early 1982.
and that's when
um the people behind the UK distribution
of the movie The driller killer which
like I said is Abel Ferreira uh who's a
New York filmmaker who's made like some
pretty little killer is good but miss 45
is my favorite
um but yeah so they were uh that was a
1979 film and they were trying to sell
the movie obviously because they're
trying to make money off it so they take
out this full page ad in a bunch of like
video magazines and this ad showed
um you know a very iconic image from the
movie which is essentially like somebody
like putting a drill into somebody's
forehead and it's like pretty graphic
and [ __ ] like that's obviously not real
but you know what I mean it's it's a
pretty like striking image
so because this ad kind of like got
around uh people started bitching about
it and crying
uh and they started complaining to uh a
body they had over there called the
advertising standards agency
so there was that so I kind of feel like
at that point like stuff started getting
more you know people started being more
aware of it oh my God this stuff is out
there and it's unregulated and maybe we
should do something about that and then
a couple months after that
um this other company that was
Distributing Cannibal Holocaust which we
talked about before
um they decided that they were going to
send an anonymous letter
to Mary Whitehouse who was the
um she was in this thing called like the
national viewers and listeners
Association so they thought that they
could drum up more publicity by like
writing to her anonymously and
complaining about their own movie
what ended up happening though was that
I mean as funny as that is
it kind of worked but then it also kind
of backfired because it ended up that
Mary Whitehouse was so incensed by the
existence of these that she essentially
like spearheaded I don't know if she
like spearheaded but she definitely
became like the face of it she basically
like became like at the Forefront of we
needed to do something about these
unregulated like these you know this
filth that's proliferating like in the
UK and like corrupting the youth and
everything so she started off this whole
big public campaign and I think she
might have been the one that coined the
term video nasty as I said nasty
referring to
like uh kind of like smut or violence in
book form like I said like kind of the
paperback that had been in use I think
until since the 1970s like particularly
talk about stuff like
um you know like kind of like the
paperback horror like Pulp horror kind
of like James Herbert or something like
that
um that had been referred to by that
term before like like I said like Nazi
exploitation or [ __ ] like that so it had
been used in that sense but I think she
was the one that put video and nasty
together like and that became a thing so
yeah and then that point like later that
year like in summer of 1982 there was
basically this really big article that
came out
um I think it was the Sunday yeah the
Sunday Times and it came out um and it
was called How High Street horror is
invading the home and it was kind of
like informing everybody in the UK it's
like hey these movies are unregulated so
it's like little kids can just toddle
down to the [ __ ] Corner Shop and rent
them and there's all kind of like
horrible [ __ ] in there like Cannibal
Holocaust so we needed to do something
about this and it became like a a big
huge [ __ ] deal and as I said like the
daily mail
um really got on board with that because
like I said it probably sold papers
their whole thing is outraging anyway I
think they're like kind of still around
actually when I was over there they said
everybody I bet they said they either
called it the daily fail or the daily
heil
that's what they called it over there
but yeah so I mean everybody I knew
that's what they called it over there so
they were kind of on the Forefront of
the [ __ ] too like just printing [ __ ]
about these movies all the time
and they were blaming these movies for
pretty much everything like every time
there was like oh there was an increase
in crime oh these video nasties it's
like they're the ones they're you know
life is cheap and the kids are watching
these and blah blah even though like I
said Prime probably I don't know I kind
of feel like like you said
um when I was a little kid
I really liked horror movies I probably
saw some [ __ ] that I maybe shouldn't
have seen like earlier than I should
have seen it but I think most kids do
that because they're curious they're
curious and it's like it doesn't
traumatize you for life or anything it's
like if it's real scary or [ __ ] up it
might give you like nightmares or like
you know some stress or something like
that but it's not gonna like warp your
whole entire [ __ ] personality for
Christ's sake I think it should scare
you
yeah I learned a lot about being scared
I would honestly advocate for I'm a big
fan of like I don't want to like
traumatize kids for life but I'm a big
Advocate I think most kids it depends on
the kid it depends on the individual kid
you know your own kid better than anyone
else but when I was a kid I really liked
scary [ __ ] like I was attracted to that
kind of thing I think a lot of kids are
attracted to that kind of stuff and I
think that as a parent I don't think
there's anything wrong with letting them
explore that I think it's probably good
I think it's healthy because it's like
look the real world is kind of [ __ ] up
I think by that's a that's a group fairy
tales we're all about that's what I'm
saying it's like you know yeah like
protect your kid as much as you can it's
like you know don't tell them like the
most horrible [ __ ] like it has to be age
appropriate I'm not saying like I said
you [ __ ] like a Serbian filmed like a
[ __ ] five-year-old that would be
terrible but I'm just saying that you
know within the age range I think it's
healthy for them to learn that scary
[ __ ] happens sometimes bad things happen
to good people sometimes you know what I
mean and just kind of introduce that to
them slowly and I think scary movies is
a good way of doing that because it's a
safe way of doing that I kind of feel
like I don't know and like I said this
isn't true across the board but I kind
of feel like kids that grew up
watching scary [ __ ] not super scary
because you know I I didn't watch
anything like really really horrible
until it was like eight or nine or ten
maybe like then I started watching
slasher movies and they scared me but
not for long like after a while I was
like well I was it's fake you know what
I mean
you know but I really liked scary stuff
ghost stories and all that kind of stuff
when I was really little
but I kind of feel like it helps you
deal with reality a little bit better
you know yeah because you're already
used to oh well [ __ ] up [ __ ] happens
yeah like so it's so it's a lot easier
for for you to deal with the real world
completely tougher bad [ __ ] happens to
you and stuff like that like I said it's
age-appropriate introduce
but you know it I mean if you're really
into horror and you have kids and you
kind of want to get them into it then
you know there's a lot of resources
nowadays where there's like kind of
age-appropriate horror like yeah
introduce it slowly start with the
universal monsters yeah start with
something like that that's not like
super super scary that's what I started
on and there's stuff like miraculous
friends you know like nowadays like what
you know or from my era you know stuff
like the gate or like from 1987 or the
lady in white or something like that
which is scary it's like a ghost story
actually the lady was like a murderer
mystery too
um but you know it was scary but it
wasn't like so scary that like kids
would be [ __ ] traumatized for life or
anything today's kid probably bored as
Hell by [ __ ] the old Dracula and
stuff probably too slow for him maybe
yeah because that's the thing a lot of
them are like really talky which might
not and that's the thing it's funny too
because I was watching a documentary I
loved them but they didn't have any
choice when I was a kid right 70s yeah
you didn't really have a lot of I mean
nowadays there's like so much
competition you're watching them by
yourself elf you know what I mean you're
[ __ ] sitting on the floor in front of
the television I could see how some
images of them would still be scary but
like I feel like in the Aggregate and
the funny thing was like I was watching
a documentary about video nasties
earlier and like one of the guys on
there that had grown up during that era
and he's like yeah it's like you know
it's he's like in some ways like exactly
what Mary Whitehouse and all the [ __ ]
old bitties and stuff like that were
like afraid would happen it's like yeah
the the parents would go out to the pub
or whatever and then we'd sneak out to
the corner shop and like rent some
horror movies but he's like the thing
about it was like that you know
everybody would talk about oh this is
the worst one this is so [ __ ] up it's
like most of the time you'd rent them
it's like most of them they were just
boring you know what I mean it's like
you're trying to like fast forward
through like where's the [ __ ] up [ __ ]
the best slasher for kids is Terror
trained because you never it's not very
it's not very graphic I don't think they
ever show anybody actually get killed do
they
wait dude
yeah yeah well people get killed a lot
of people get killed I don't think they
actually show it I think so I think they
show the aftermath yeah and they don't
but they happen in a lot of slashes yeah
they don't show anybody
being killed I don't even think there's
much blood in it but they show the dead
body yeah I mean it's not like a [ __ ]
you know like a Suspiria situation where
you see a like knife going into like an
actual open heart you know what I mean I
saw that around 13 or 14 maybe 13 when I
saw it and I liked it because it scared
me because your imagination would run
away with you
but it never repelled me from like you
know
Gore
and then later I saw Friday the 13th
and I thought that [ __ ] was gory but
I'll go back and look at it there's not
much in Friday the 13th they don't it's
not as gory as I remember it's
surprising and yeah we and we have like
all the we have the whole collection and
we have like the unrated ones and I was
like wow this is like way Tamer than I
remember yeah there's something there's
like nothing in there something about
the score and the settings that you know
being out at night in the in this at
Camp Crystal Lake
although I remember liking the second
one much better the second I did too I
do too second one's the best one I would
I think the second one's the best one
out of mall I think we've said that
before but yeah I think this I think
Friday the 13th is is SEC that part two
is the best one out of the series I
think the second one was for me when
that came out that was [ __ ] heavy I
was like whoa yeah I mean whoa be that
[ __ ] make your heart [ __ ] go and
[ __ ] man that's some sick [ __ ] that's
like his soul leaving his body yeah
trying to stop my astral projections
that's what happens that's what happens
at the club that's how we know when he's
drunk because he starts going like that
like he's coming to join you Elizabeth
yeah yeah yeah like because I'm like is
your soul eating your problem
but I think I teased him about that at
mannequins I was like are you going to
join Elizabeth yeah and then angel came
over here
started trying to hold my soul
angels are French
and because I said you were going to
join yeah and then uh
yeah it was but I was just uh the second
one when you when they when uh you get
to to Jason's Lair and he's got the
sweater
and the ham sweater in the head yeah and
then she like put the sweater on put the
sweater on I was like man that was
[ __ ] up yeah it's like gross in that
day that was in that day like she's
hardcore as you're watching all this
horror stuff unravel that was some big
[ __ ] if you were [ __ ] 13 14 you know
when that was happening I might have
been I might have been a little bit
younger actually
I have a hard time remembering how old I
was that was what Friday the 13th 2 was
80.
81 81. 82 well I think the first one
came out in 1980 right
so first about 13 and 14 around that
time and I'm pretty sure they came out
like pretty much every year about 13. so
I think it was 81. yeah and I was uh I
was [ __ ] up by that but in a good way
I was like that think about it you know
and I would see that I saw that a summer
or visiting my dad up in Mississippi and
it looks like that you know it's rural
so you're you're always thinking maybe
you might
Jason looking into you know into the
house through the window they never no
it could happen yeah or you're outside
put on a [ __ ] hockey mask
you know what's weird though it's like
as much as I love horror
and and I love all kinds of horror like
I'll watch anything I don't give a [ __ ]
like um you know I like sub some sub
genres more than others but I'm not
picky like I'll just pretty much I'll
give anything a shot
but if something's gonna like legit
scare me it's gonna be like Supernatural
it's gonna be like a ghost story
slasher movies and in home invasion
horror and stuff like that like a lot of
those I really like them but for
whatever reason they don't scare me even
though those could totally happen and
like the ghost story [ __ ] totally can't
I don't understand why that is and I've
tried to like figure it out and I don't
know I don't know
um let's see
wow the Daily Mail was already like that
40 years ago yeah I kind of feel like
that's their whole business model I mean
that's that was kind of the whole thing
back then they were really on the
Forefront of this campaign against the
video nasties and like I said every time
some [ __ ] up crime happened and like I
said later on like the hunger for masker
the Hungerford Massacre like when that
guy like went and shot up all those
people like in the UK
um yeah they blamed that on horror
movies
oh did we get a Super Chat yeah oh thank
you Emily you guys should watch the 2020
BBC version of Dracula yeah that's like
I had heard about that I think we did we
start watching it I kind of feel like
that's like really 2020 not that okay
then uh that's really familiar what's
his name wasn't talking about that Brian
tennold wasn't talking about the 2020
BBC was he
was talking about the old BBC you're not
not branded tunnel but James from Center
Massacre yeah James from Cinema that's
right no he wasn't no he was talking
about the 70s 70s yeah that's like yeah
that's like a newer one because that
video is like a couple years old where
he was talking about like this the
Dracula stuff yeah there was like some
uh hold on there was like some questions
that I missed we're gonna like a lot of
comments on this it's like it's hard for
me to keep track of them uh Rebecca says
hi folks I'm late as usual well you're
in Australia so you know fair enough
this will be my go-to watch tomorrow
night we're kind of like all over the
place but that's okay we're just I mean
honestly we're talking about video
nasties but it's like you just kind of
like talking about like [ __ ] up horror
movies which is like that's that's
totally fun
um Rebecca said I was watching horror
and True Crime as a five plus year old I
totally agree that I learned that scary
stuff is worldly yeah I would like I
said I would argue that I don't know I
just think it's healthy I think it's
healthy for kids to get it so like I
said if they want to I don't think you
should like force it on them if they
don't like it because I know some kids
are maybe more sensitive than others but
I liked spooky [ __ ] I wanted to watch
Spooky [ __ ] even if it scared me because
I kind of feel like when I was a kid
it's like going on a roller coaster yeah
it was like that like I was really into
like and sometimes I'd have nightmares
or sometimes I couldn't sleep after I
saw it but I still wanted to watch it I
started off watching like the universal
monsters and the old black and white
Twilight zones episodes that's where I
got introduced some of those Twilight
zones are like pretty nice yeah that's
where I that's where I uh got uh I guess
you could say uh introduced to like
horror and sci-fi and
[ __ ] like and then the Night Gallery
that scared the [ __ ] out oh my God I
love nightgown yeah I still love Night
Gallery yeah Night Gallery is so good I
think yeah I think that was one of the
things that got me into I mean I was
like into funny [ __ ] too like The Adams
Family and stuff but it's just kind of
like
um I think maybe Night Gallery was one
of my earliest or maybe it was Twilight
Zone because that was you know that's
like before my time obviously but they
were like repeated on TV all the time
Legend 007 says Gen X people told him
how they would be traumatized by Return
to Oz that had furusa bulk in it I'm
definitely gonna be reviewing that
because I know like you guys because you
asked about because I did Ricky
dicky-tavi and I did like a lot I was
talking about stuff that like
traumatized Our Generation like when
they were younger and Return to Oz is
one that comes up a lot and I was like
yeah I totally need to do a video on
that because there was some [ __ ] up
[ __ ] in that movie like it is it's
really good but like I said that's what
I mean that was that whole 80s era where
you saw even [ __ ] that was ostensibly
for kids like like The Dark Crystal and
stuff like that had some really like
scary [ __ ] in it and I'm a big advocate
of that I think that's like I think
that's cool the Disney animated movie
Black Cauldron is supposed to be really
good I've never seen it yeah and I did
it now you can't get it can you yeah you
can I thought Disney got rid of it no no
I can't get it okay well I did a video
the other day because somebody asked me
about
um The Watcher in the woods which was uh
a Disney it was a live action movie and
it was an adaptation of a novel and it
came out like in 1980 1981 or something
like that like early 80s and so I was
talking about I did a video where I was
talking about like Disney's dark phase
quote unquote which included Black
Cauldron also like the black hole
um you know movies where they were
trying to be like go like skew toward
like a slightly older audience and so
like slightly darker like Something
Wicked This Way Comes That was another
one like the Ray Ray Bradbury adaptation
so
um so that was the thing I kind of feel
like they did kind of go in that
direction for a little while and a lot
of even though none of those movies were
all that financially successful
um this many years later like people of
Our Generation still remember them
because that was something that like
really made an impact when they were
growing up like I said like kids love
scary [ __ ] you love scary [ __ ] and you
like remember the first scary [ __ ] that
you saw and I didn't see Watcher in the
woods back in the day but I did see
Black Cauldron I did see black hole I
saw that in the theater actually which
actually kind of like freaked me out a
little bit as of that one scene where
like that big Fireball was like coming
up the thing like I remember that
growing up as in a kid as a kid in
California going to a Disneyland half a
Disneyland was scary
back in those days yeah you had snow
white which is a scary ride
it was no way it was very yeah I
remember scare I remember snow white
being like one of the scariest guys that
[ __ ] witch comes out and screaming
it's [ __ ] super loud and there's like
it's got I think it doesn't have a heart
or no it well that was kind of well that
was the whole point of the story was
that she was she wanted Snow White's
heart like to prove that the Huntsman
had killed her yeah so it's like bring
back her heart in this life yeah and
then there's a [ __ ]
that's in the cartoon and everything the
mirror was talking to her it was a good
ride I think it's gone now
I think it was it wasn't really up to
Snuff to Modern standards well I mean I
was just I mean me and my sister just
went to Disney World uh you know about a
month ago and yeah I don't think Snow
White Peter Pan is still there
um yeah there's like other rides like
that of that same caliber that are still
a haunted house uh was pretty scary when
you were a kid
um the the Pirates of the Caribbean was
pretty scary when you could but you
liked it yeah just because it was scary
to me you didn't like it well yeah those
were I mean let's do it again you know
there's a reason why those were e-ticket
rides like from back in the day when you
had to like pay for tickets like for
each ride those were the big deal and uh
the Matterhorn it had the [ __ ]
abdominal the abdominal heavy abdominals
that's you that's me it had the
Abominable Snowman in it you know it's
like uh the Disney World doesn't have a
a Matterhorn I don't know no we have um
here we have like I said we have Space
Mountain we have the Big Thunder
Mountain Railroad which is like a mining
train which is super fun it's the
equivalent of yeah and we have Splash
Mountain right which is kind of like a
water Flume but it's also kind of like a
little Disney World is bigger is bigger
but uh uh Disneyland has a couple of
extra rides on there they're pretty cool
had one we had a rocket you can this
rocket that would Spin and you got into
the cars that were flying around you
could go up and down on them
yeah I remember we used to have that I
don't think it's there anymore probably
not there anymore but there's when I was
there last time I was surprised because
they remember like the Dumbo Ride Like
the elephants or whatever they still
have that but they moved it somewhere
else and then where that was they put
like a similar ride but it's like
Aladdin so it's like magic carpets
Disneyland had What's called the future
the city of the future I think the city
of tomorrow or future land is future
land is it called future land yeah what
was funny is that the future land even
in 1980 still looked like 1961. yeah
yeah I kind of like that now because now
it's like retro it's retro is [ __ ] but
it's called future land but it looks
like so now it's like kind of awesome
yeah you had the [ __ ] people mover
they're doing a big Tron thing there
yeah they're they're building it because
my sister showed me we did we run around
like the people mover and she said yeah
they're putting like she showed where
they were tearing out all the stuff and
yeah it's next to like where the um the
like race cars are yeah you know those
race car rides um she's like yeah
they're doing this whole thing and it's
gonna be like a big Tron it's it's a try
on Ride Like based on the Disneyland had
one that that they don't have here it's
called the uh the Monsanto ride we call
it the Monsanto Riders I think it's
called The Voyage the Inner Space I
think is what it was called where you're
waiting in line it's like you're gonna
go to some kind of space launch and and
they try to convince you that they've
shrunk you down and they keep shrinking
you down and to the size of where you
can see chemicals of molecules because
[ __ ] Monsanto was a chemical company
so they're trying to show you how
awesome chemicals were like it was a
cool ride here why don't you go into
someone's like small intestine yeah we
have now the size when they come out
their poop hole you are now looking at
the nucleus of an atom and it's like
well okay but it's just a round ball
with a bunch of light shots we had that
but it was at Epcot Epcot okay and I
don't think it was a ride ride I think
it was a walk through okay now I can't
remember it was a long time ago when
California Road in it I can't remember
what it was called though yeah you got
into body Wars you got into it basically
it was a doom buggy like from uh the
Haunted Mansion I mean I'm gonna say
like I said I just was at Disney world
like about a month ago and the Haunted
Mansion is still the OG yeah I mean
space mountains rad uh you know uh Big
Thunder Mountain Railroad is still Rad
but the Haunted Mansion is still like
it's the most creative it's the most fun
it still is like even after all this we
had a friend who worked there and
there's a part in the in the Haunted
Mansion here in Florida
where this ghostly woman comes at you
and she's got a knife and she's she's
counting out how many husbands she
killed and then like
a a [ __ ] ax appears in her hands and
she looks like a 3D ghost I mean it
looks like it's there
and it's morphing and moving as it
starts
and I said man that's an amazing effect
how the [ __ ] do you how the [ __ ] do you
guys do that well okay but he finally
spilled the beans I'm not gonna say
because I don't remember exactly but
when he told me how it was done it was
it was stupid as [ __ ] that [ __ ]
fooled me and it's like yeah that's all
it is you can go to Spirit Halloween and
get the same thing for like thirty
dollars what's that like of the same
kind of projection effect yeah very
common nowadays yeah it looks like it's
standing right there it's very easy to
do and it looks like it's standing right
there and it's moving and talking and
saying things and she's and she's a
beautiful woman in this wedding
gown and it's [ __ ] flowing and you
can kind of slightly see through her she
looks 3D and then she's still death to
us part and her [ __ ] hand comes out
and her [ __ ] ax comes out the ax
appears in her hand it's [ __ ] creepy
as [ __ ]
see when I was a little kid that was my
favorite thing yeah I think she reaches
up bad ass puts her hand up like that in
a [ __ ] bottle of poison [ __ ]
materializes in it she does all kinds of
cool [ __ ] she I went through that
several times to try to because she's
counting down how many she killed and
each one was different
and I wanted to hear them all
they had them all all up on YouTube but
then they took that down Disney you
can't put that there everything that she
says
you have to go you have to go through
the ride probably about seven or eight
times just by chance to to in order to
record everything she says because she's
she's going through a whole monologue
yeah like I said I'm still gonna say I
think that attic thing was added later
because I don't remember that before I
didn't remember that from when I was a
kid like going on the Haunted Mansion
because we used to get I mean I grew up
in Central Florida she was a character
from some movie that that Disney made
and she was killing all her husbands or
something it was from one I think maybe
from the Eddie Murphy movie or was or
was just that must have been I didn't
see the Eddie Murphy Haunted Mansion
yeah because I was like man don't
besmirch my [ __ ] favorite ride like
that don't make a movie out of that [ __ ]
buggy goes up into the attic [ __ ]
chests and [ __ ] all this [ __ ] that
she's stolen from all these dudes that
she's killed in the damn attic
you see other pictures her pictures of
all the her and her dollar dead husbands
and when you come around the bed you can
see her from a distance and she's
sitting in a corner just as glowing
greenish blue
3D ghost man it looks like it's just
hang in there in space it looks real
looks really good I was like how the
[ __ ] are they doing that and uh it's
it's obviously some kind of projection
but it looks like you pass it and you
can see it from the side like it's 3D
but you can see right through it
and he told me how it how they did it
but uh I forgot and when he told me it
was so so simple and so stupid I never
would have most of it's like I said it's
the same tricks that they used to use
back at the carnival like back before
they even had [ __ ] anything yeah like
a lot of it's just like projection and
mirrors that's all it is injections and
mirrors and they were all you have to do
is like arrange the mirrors in a correct
way and have the projector in the right
place and it's like you can make all
kind of crazy [ __ ] yeah
uh let's see do to do mango says I still
remember the first horror movie I
watched Taste the Blood of Dracula oh
that's a good one I was about four or
five scared the hell out of me and I
never looked back I can't remember like
I said I grew up like watching I think
my first thing
I got into horror movies probably when I
was like seven or eight but I think
prior to that
um you know I learned to read pretty
young and the first things that I wanted
to read were like ghost stories or
stories about witches I really liked
ghost stories and witch stories so every
time I would go to the library I'd
always like look for those big
compilation books it's like you know the
big book of witches or whatever so I'd
always like read that kind of stuff I
think maybe
I'm trying to think of like the first
horror movie that I remember seeing I
remember seeing The Shining that came
out in 1980 right uh yeah I think so so
okay so I was eight when it came out in
the theater but I don't think I saw it
in the theater because my parents
wouldn't they weren't that cool they
wouldn't like take me to see The Shining
but whenever it was on cable I saw it
then it scared the [ __ ] [ __ ] out of
me but I still wanted to like see it
again it gave me nightmares but I wanted
to see it again also I remember seeing
My Bloody Valentine which I think
somebody mentioned that came out in 1981
when I was nine
and I think I saw that maybe when I was
10 years old and that also scared the
[ __ ] out of me I had like a nightmare
about like a minor like popping out my
closet and like
killing me with a pickaxe
but I still like and I don't think I
slept that night I went I went toddling
out of my room and like slept on the
couch and my mom was like why are you
sleeping on the couch I was like is that
pickaxe fan in my closet but um you know
I was like 10. and uh you know but after
that I was like I kind of like that
experience though I wanted to like see
that again so
I mean as long as I can remember I've
always been a like creepy [ __ ] that's
all I wanted to watch even if they
scared me
you know I wanted to go back and see
them Rebecca says uh talking about kids
throw them in the water so to speak
Silver Bullet oh yeah that's a good one
uh Lost Boys Freddy yeah scream seven
for today the beer Street Trilogy yeah I
kind of feel like nowadays there's a lot
of stuff that is
scary but like is still like a pro like
age appropriate for like little kids you
know what I mean like you could show
them like all kind of stuff nowadays
like there's I think in the 90s they
have like the Goosebumps series and even
nowadays you can show them something
like you know scary stories to tell in
the dark that Guillermo del Toro movie
like you could show them that because
that's kind of like geared it's slightly
sort of like a younger audience but and
then as they got older like you could
show them and like I said there was a
lot of movies like that in the 80s that
were like kind of scary but you know
we're still like not really really bad
weren't like a [ __ ] slasher movie and
I would even argue that even some
slasher movies and horror movies that
came out in the 70s and 80s you could
probably still show those to a kid and
they wouldn't be all that upset about it
like you know what I mean considering
like all the [ __ ] [ __ ] they see
nowadays once you catch up with the
okay well yeah you always let it go get
back well I don't let it get by it's
just I try to answer the stuff but
you're talking so it's like she blames
it on me no I'm just saying that
sometimes you're talking about when I
interrupt you
so
uh yeah you also gotta uh I know I got
that I got that I got that
I know I got really behind okay okay
um yeah they're talking about Monster
Squad yeah that's a good one to like to
show to kids I think that was 87. uh
Mega said Insidious and Sinister are the
last films that really scared me
Sinister is a great movie I remember
Insidious being good too but Sinister
was like really really good I haven't
seen the second one I don't know if it's
any good or not but
I think Sinister was so good because
well Ethan Hawke was great in it but I
don't know I just like the whole concept
and like the whole concept of like the
videos that he found was like super
creepy but I haven't seen the second one
Rebecca's like oh my goodness so okay
um mega said it was okay started off
okay but went downhill okay
well I'll watch it one of these days
yeah Return to Oz like I said I'm gonna
review that one of these days so we
mentioned Song of the South I reckon you
can you can find some uh Song of the
South it's a good movie it's got really
good music real uh good um uh Southern
traditional African-American stories in
it it's it's I I think it's a beautiful
movie I don't think they ever should got
rid of it it wasn't racist well you know
at the um very Southern there's a movie
of its time and at Disney world like
Splash Mountain is based on that is
based on that I think they're changing
it up like I mean it's been like that
for a long time I think they're changing
it up to a more recent movie which is
Princess and the Frog but um because you
know there's frogs they wouldn't have to
change it all that much and I don't
think think kids nowadays have seen Song
of the South yeah but if you look you
can find Song of the South on YouTube A
lot of times bootleg and you'll see in
the comment sections you know black
people are going like why is this bad
this is all traditional African-American
stories and there's nothing racist about
this is it's it's about the Antebellum
South after after slavery and
reconstruction and Uncle Remus [ __ ]
telling his [ __ ] stories you know and
it's it's a great story it's a great
movie and the singing's great and that
guy should have got an Oscar for that
they wanted to give him an Oscar
his [ __ ] singing is [ __ ] fantastic
Adriana says Erie Indiana the gate and
the Monster Squad were spooky and also
had heart in them great ingredients for
horror for kids yeah if you're looking
for some like 80s kind of [ __ ] I always
say like the gate I love the gate like
it came out like I said I think it was
87 that's a great horror movie it's
scary but it's still you can still show
it to like a kid and they wouldn't be
too traumatized same with monster squad
because that has like scary [ __ ] in it
like people die and stuff but it's still
like kind of funny also so it's like it
hits like a really good um like balance
uh Ben says 101 Dalmatians was very
scary I mean just the idea of like this
woman that's like I'm gonna skin all
these [ __ ] dogs Jesus Christ that's
like that's traumatic nowadays yeah uh
legendra 007 said I love this scary
three-headed troll robot in the
Norwegian ride at Epcot Center yeah I
remember that I haven't been at Epcot in
a long time but I remember that ride uh
I'm sad they got rid of it I kind of
want to go like my sister's coming back
down in early December and if I have the
money which I probably won't but if I
had the money I kind of wanted to go and
like do some Park hopping because I've
been at Epcot like for a really long
time and I don't even know what they
have there anymore like she knows but
because she goes a lot but Rebecca said
the Haunted Mansion even as an adult the
first time around was creepy it's funny
because I've been on it a million times
and I was trying to this last time that
I went
I was trying to like think
what it would be like if you'd never
been on it before because there was a
there was a family in front of us who
had a little kid who was probably
three or four he had a little I mean it
was the Halloween like Disney like
Mickey's Not So Scary Halloween party so
the kid had a little costume on I think
he was a minion
and uh he was screaming from the second
they taught you know because you when
you go to the Haunted Mansion like they
bring in that first room you know what I
mean like before you get on the dune
buggy and they're doing like the
stretching portraits and all that that
kid was screaming his [ __ ] head off
like before like as soon as they got in
the room and I said oh this kid's gonna
have a really bad time and so they were
in the in the buggy in front of us and
that kid screamed the whole [ __ ] ride
but like by the end of it I think he'd
kind of like got through it because we
saw him like get off and he seemed all
right after that I said that kid's gonna
be okay he was like scared shitless
though and I was thinking to myself like
well I was because I was when I was on
it because I've been on it a bunch of
times and I was trying to think like if
I was like a [ __ ] three or
four-year-old kid that had never seen
anything like this this would probably
be really scary I mean if you're coming
at it from that point of view the
Haunted Mansion at Disney is probably
really scary the whole thing it's like
really really dark
um you know everything there's like this
creepy voice and like all this creepy
music and it's like there's [ __ ] [ __ ]
popping out at you all the time so I
kind of feel like yeah I could see why
why that kid was like scared but you
know how long have you been running
um two hours and 40. okay minutes you
getting hungry two hours yeah it's
almost a three hour show I know and it's
like I feel like I haven't even hardly
talked about the topic at all well we
actually kind of have been talking about
I mean weekly I guess this is the second
time we've done this topic so that's
true yeah that's true
but you know I just felt kind of bad
because I was like I was so stressed out
because I was like oh my God I'm not
ready I'm not ready no more they're
ready I'm not though yeah
um
Legend 007 said he he parents complain
Gremlins and Temple of dim or PG and
scared their kids that's why Steven
Spielberg recommended the invention of
PG-13 I know but that's I mean it's
[ __ ] stupid it is but it's like I can
see okay I can see why that happened
though because Gremlins and Temple of
Doom okay Gremlins has these little
monsters I don't think it was so much
the little monsters I think it was the
scene where the mom puts the gremlin in
the blender and like chops them all up
because even then I was like oh dude
that's not cool that's that's a living
creature let's not do that
um and Temple of Doom had you know them
like tearing out someone's heart so even
though like kids were watching that but
like I said it's you know it's fine kids
can handle it it's scary but
I kind of feel like
I think that's why kids like those
because they felt like the movie wasn't
talking down to them it was like it
seemed like you were seeing something
that was kind of like adult and it had
respect for you because it's like look I
know this is scary but you can handle it
you know what I mean I think that's like
a lot more respectful than kind of like
trying to like pander
to like a younger uh crowd Victor says
someone give me some horror movie
recommendations any platform well like I
said um since we haven't even like
[ __ ] bothered talking about this
topic so let's go down to the list yeah
we'll go to the list of video nasties
that's what we'll talk about because you
know obviously we're talking about some
other [ __ ] because we were talking about
before like and I kind of got like uh
off somebody asked you what your
favorite video nasty was what mine was
yeah I don't know what's on well that's
what I'm saying um some of these I know
you haven't seen like um the the 39 that
were prosecuted films these were ones
that were successfully prosecuted in one
way or another like either somebody got
fined or arrested from or they were like
seized or whatever
um some of these probably like I said
you haven't seen absurd I don't think
you've seen that one uh anthropophages
the beast that's like the the man-eating
guy
um I also love I love that the Wikipedia
list also has all of the alternate
titles for some reason I'm really into
like horror movie alternate titles they
always like make me laugh
ax like I said a bay of blood uh which
is that is a classic everybody's
familiar everybody she's there it's
Maria Baba yeah like I said it's a
really
um very early like a produce Lasher if
you see it if you see it I even have
like a little poster I don't know if you
can see it like honestly but he had this
anger that's that's bad blood right back
there although I prefer the title twitch
of the death nerve I think that's a way
better title
yeah
it's it's like Friday the 13th except
spoiler alert everyone's the killer like
everyone's well it's killing everybody
else pretty much well the whole thing
like the whole um the whole plot of the
movie revolves around this Bay obviously
like all this property around this Bay
and they're all trying to like
um get like very like inheritance and
like they're all trying to get this land
so it turns out like you don't know this
until the end but like it's I mean it's
an old movie so but like I said spoiler
alert
um it turns out that the killer isn't
just one person like everybody at least
kills one other person like in the thing
so everybody's the killer like
essentially
um let's see beast in heat
uh or SS hellcamp that's its other name
I don't know that one Blood Feast that's
good old Herschel Gordon Lewis uh which
was very very early that might be the
first splatter film I don't think I know
that one we should probably review that
one I know we've done uh we did a couple
H.G Lewis films did we not have I done
Color Me blood red I feel like I maybe
reviewed Color Me blood red which is my
favorite one I don't know why I have
affection for that one Blood Feast it's
not a great movie I'm not saying that
but
it was way way ahead of his time
um you know it came out in the 60s
and it's basically about like this
Egyptian
ritual where you like cut a person apart
and there's like cannibalism and stuff
and it's pretty I mean it looks pretty
um cheap and shitty by today's standards
but for the 1960s it's like pretty out
there
so I mean there's a reason why H.G Lewis
is still remembered to this day he was
the first dude that was doing splatter
flicks pretty much uh the burning that
was uh to Tom savini's early work that
was uh which I don't even remember that
being that gory so I don't know cannibal
apocalypse cannibal ferrox cannibal
Holocaust you had cannibal in the title
you had cannibal in the title they were
gonna put you they didn't even give a
[ __ ] don't go in the woods Thriller
killer like I said I really like to like
drill a killer evil speak uh good one I
like evil speaking Yeah he likes evil
speaking that's good I recommend that
one yeah that's a good movie actually
yeah I mean in the military academy
[ __ ] summoning the devil it's cheesy
but yeah but through his Apple to eat or
whatever it was uh Faces of Death and
there may be several versions of that of
of evil speak because uh my boy sent me
another version of this longer I haven't
seen it again Brian
yeah yeah it says like the UK at least
in the terms of this it says that it was
released in 87 with three minutes and 34
seconds cut out yeah as I mentioned but
it was re-released uncut in the UK in
2004. so recommendation on this list
evil speak okay that's one I can
recommend Faces of Death yeah which like
I said
um flesh for Frankenstein I actually I
actually really like flesh for
Frankenstein we reviewed that not too
long ago do you remember that the Andy
Warhol flesh for frankincense yeah yeah
yeah that one's a lot of fun yeah that
was a lot of fun
um here I don't recommend that over evil
speak though he would like evil speak
over that probably that one that one
you're talking about that that's an
expert you gotta have expert taste for
that one and it's [ __ ] it's hilarious
in a way uh it's very Camp real campy
but yeah see out of what I heard so far
I recommend evil speak that's a good one
let's see it should be famous it's not
that famous I don't know why that
movie's well yeah it's just the timing
it's almost kind of like Evil Dead let's
say at that level it's a dude no evil
evil dead is way more famous you know
I'm talking about the quality wise it's
kind of like Evil Dead in a way or mate
uh dude hulks out with the power of
Satan and [ __ ] kills a bunch of
people and weird [ __ ] happens I liked it
uh let's see I I was laughing at this
one like before we started the show uh
there's a movie called The gestapo's
Last orgy which I don't think I've
actually seen I have seen some Nazis
exploitation I saw like all the ilsa She
Wolf of the SS I saw all those uh but
the reason this made me laugh is because
one of its alternate titles is Caligula
reincarnated as Hitler
which I don't know why that movie laughs
so much but it's like it did uh another
one that was on the band list was housed
by the cemetery the Lucio volche classic
I don't understand
why that would be on there
um but I really like house by the
cemetery not as good as the Beyond but
I don't know house by the cemetery is
good house by the cemetery is good it's
not as surreal as the Beyond I think
that's probably why I don't like it as
much but and the dubbing of The Kid Bob
is ridiculous but I think that's like
why a lot of people like it
is because of that doping he's I mean
it's a memorable character that's for
sure uh as I said I Spit on Your Grave
that's on there too which I I actually
like that it's pretty good I like that
movie yeah it's all right I like that
movie I don't know I have an affection
for that movie last house on the left is
a [ __ ] classic that's Wes Craven uh
like I said again not a pleasant movie
to watch but it's undeniably like a
[ __ ] well-made [ __ ] movie with a
lot of thought behind it you know what
I'm saying
uh let's see what else is on here mad
house uh which actually that's one I've
been wanting to cover for a long time
love Camp seven that was another kind of
like Nazi exploitation uh nightmares and
a damage brain that one's pretty good I
haven't seen it in a long time
uh night of the bloody Apes that's
terrible
uh night of the demon the only thing
that was the Bigfoot one right the only
thing I remember about that one was the
dude getting his dick ripped off yeah
which made me laugh but that's the only
thing I can remember yeah that's not
noteworthy not really um and I think
that was why it got on that list because
that dude getting his dick ripped off uh
snuff which like I said was purported to
be like a real snuff movie obviously it
wasn't um you know and if you watched it
that would be very clear uh SS
experiment camp that was another one
tenebrae which I don't understand the
Dario Argento movie what why is that on
there yeah it's violent
um you know maybe it was the scene where
that girl gets her arm cut off with a
machete and then she like goes like that
there's like a big lovely spray of blood
like across the mall which is like a
great [ __ ] scene Tanner Bray is a
great movie that's like probably one of
his best yellow movies like not I mean
his best yellow movies like probably
deep red but tenebrae is good too uh the
werewolf and the yeti
and uh Lucio fulchi's in the UK it was
called zombie flesh eaters over here
it's just called Zombie I've it's also
called Zombie two crappy movie it's good
Zombie's good there's no zombies in it
yeah there are what are you talking
about I think yeah they're zombies at
the very yeah but the zombie in that one
you have to admit that is one of the
best cinematic zombies yeah I mean with
the [ __ ] worms coming out of his eye
and all that kind of [ __ ] that's [ __ ]
fantastic I had to wait forever to see a
zombie I'm gonna I'm going to bat for
Lucio faulty though because I really
liked yeah he made well he made so many
movies and it's like everybody in the US
like everybody's into horror movies
knows Lucio faulty because of like
zombie and the Beyond and housed by the
cemetery and like City the Living Dead
and like all his like Gore movies he
made movies in all kind of genres I've
covered a couple of them
um you know I did New York Ripper not
too long ago which was like a slasher
giallo type movie he did like a lot of
geology movies honestly one of his best
movies I think was the psychic or murder
to the tune of seven black notes I was
like really into that movie it was like
a giallo but like with a little bit of a
supernatural paranormal component and I
think that's great and I think a lot of
people I'm also a big fan of like house
of clocks which he actually made for
Italian TV which is like murderous old
people and that's like pretty [ __ ] up
too I couldn't believe that they showed
some of the [ __ ] that they showed like
on on a time he made it for Italian TV
and it's like super super gory so uh so
yeah like not as gory as some of his
other stuff but it's still pretty Gory
for like for TV but yeah I've talked
about I think I talked about one of his
kind of like shittier movies the other
day not it wasn't
um not demonia what was the one that I
just talked about the other the one
about the [ __ ] Egyptian
thing that wasn't like really all that
great but yeah so there's another
section those are like the 39 that are
like the worst those were like
prosecuted and then there's like some
that are section two and these were
non-prosecuted films these were ones
that they thought were maybe
prosecutable but for whatever reason
like either the prosecution failed or
they didn't think it was worth it or
something like that uh in on that list
you had the Beyond which like I said is
a [ __ ] classic I don't understand why
that would be on there uh the boogeyman
cannibal Terror contamination dead and
buried dead and buried is a great that's
great flick film it's a great film so so
I loved Edinburgh so far I can say uh
evil evil speak and dead and buried
those are two those are yeah those are
both those are two rooms and like I said
I've seen more of these so I'm gonna go
to bat for like again tenebrae that's a
[ __ ] classic and all the Lucio folgy
ones Den Berry's kind of almost like a
pseudo zombie flick in a way dead and
buried is so good yeah it's really good
it's weird it's a weird take on zombies
Frankenstein type of deal and I feel
like a lot of people like a lot of
people don't really talk about no it
almost feels like it almost feels like a
little bit underreated that one to me
always kind of felt like a like a like a
like a stone flick
almost kind of like the Oliver Stone
almost like an Oliver Stone or a cross
between Oliver Stone and
um uh
uh [ __ ] dude who did [ __ ] video
drama and all that [ __ ] uh David
Carnival yeah yeah kind of like a
Cronenberg and an Oliver Stone flick
mashed together that's a well-made movie
and it's [ __ ] weird really weird
that's another thing now that we're
talking about video nasties how come
cronenberg's [ __ ] never got on here
because his [ __ ] is like way disturbing
yeah I guess because they thought of him
as like oh well he's an artistic
filmmaker yeah maybe so he can you can
get away with a lot more you know what I
mean maybe because well here's the thing
like if you're somebody like Cronenberg
or like David Lynch or something like
that you could put all kind of
disturbing [ __ ] in your movies and it's
like nobody's gonna get all that mad
about it because it's like oh well he's
like an auteur so you can get away with
a lot more so
yeah you know
I don't know what I'm saying the mango
knows dead and buried he says it's great
dead and buried is so good yeah that's
good I really like I said I kind of feel
like more people should see that
uh mango says Ethan Hawke is amazing in
Black phone I still haven't seen that
like the trailer looks really good I
need to see it
um and when Victor was asking for horror
movie recommendations Hugo said uh I
liked malignant I did too it's it's
crazy it's like over the top but I liked
that it leaned into it uh barbarian
barbarian is also fantastic I loved that
I haven't seen it yet um yeah I watched
it I think you'd probably like it I
think you'd like it I reviewed it for my
channel and bavarium yeah vivarium is
[ __ ] great very good I love a
variable it's a love it or hate it flick
we've seen it like five or six times I
own it I [ __ ] love it we've seen it a
bunch of times yeah
uh let's see Pat says oh yeah I haven't
watched this yet he says there's a Lucio
volci documentary on shutter which I'm
enjoying yeah I've I've been meaning to
like watch that it's like on my little
watch list
um Emily says not a video nasty but
Eddie and the Cruisers is such a
forgotten classic you know what's weird
is like we were watching because the
movie that we're going to be reviewing
for the movie retrospective this week is
the John Carpenter movie Village of the
Damned like the Remake
um we meant to record it today but we
didn't have time so it might be a little
bit late going up for patrons but it'll
be up by Friday and the guy that was in
that Michael uh paray I was like hey I
think that was the guy from Eddie and
the Cruisers Eddie and the Cruisers was
one of those movies that I don't think I
ever sat down and watched the whole
thing like all the way through but it
seemed like it was always on like every
time you were like flick flicking
through the channels like on cable I was
like oh there's anything Cruisers again
because it's like as soon as I saw that
guy in the movie I was like oh the dog
said I was like oh here that guy was
defeated the Cruisers oh my God uh let's
see Zach says my favorite favorite video
nasty is possession yeah that was kind
of like I feel like possession was like
the only art film maybe was that like
the only art film that got on the list
and honestly I don't really understand
I don't know I don't understand like why
a lot of these movies got on there like
it just seems very arbitrary to me
possession I don't remember it I haven't
seen it a long time but I don't remember
it being all that upsetting and I don't
remember anything
in there particularly that would like
upset anybody
so you know
uh mango said yeah denim buried was
banned for years which is crazy I don't
remember anything like super egregious
in that one either
um let's see mango said they were
heavily cut in the UK especially video
drone okay so cronenberg's movies were I
just kind of felt like well I was sure
they were probably cut but it's just
like it was interesting to me how none
of his stuff ever got mentioned in the
same breath as like the video nasties
and I thought maybe because it was
easier to go after like these kind of
like more cheap exploitation flicks
rather than more Art House stuff like
Cronenberg well they probably had but
mango said that they were heavily cut in
the UK like video dream was heavily cut
and I'm sure because yeah because
I kind of well wait a minute wasn't
scanners like on one of the lists
although I think I read that scanners
they passed it uncut and I was like even
the exploding head
because even by today's standards that's
pretty gory
even though that's the only problem is
this great movie I love scanners yeah I
mean I love David Cronenberg yeah
scanners isn't my favorite movie of his
but I mean he has so many [ __ ] good
ones I don't even know if I could pick
one to be honest with you
I mean dead ringers probably if you put
a gun in my head but
they're all good Jesus Christ I don't
really have to say video drone
yeah I mean video drama so nobody's
gonna argue with that yeah yeah mango
said you can get them uncut now yeah I
figured you probably could I kind of
feel like that was kind of the case
once the 2000s rolled around I think
they realized well this you know the
horse is out of the barn now so it's
like not they couldn't really control it
to any extent so most of the movies that
you know people were making such a like
a [ __ ] big [ __ ] brouhaha about
back in the day they watched them again
and they were just like oh there's
really nothing in this especially
compared to [ __ ] nowadays holy crap like
the [ __ ] that flies now that they just
show in regular theaters like I said
they should [ __ ] terrify her too
which is supposed to be like the [ __ ]
goriest movie ever
I was doing a radio I was recording a
radio show yesterday and the girl was
talking about she's like oh I just went
and saw terrifier too and I was like is
it good I kind of want to she's like
well it's kind of long she's like it's
two and a half hours and um which is
very long for a horror movie but she's
like and I really like gory movies and
even I was just kind of like like it was
a little much and I was just kind of
like well now I really want to see it
because I'm like no I'm kind of like
interested to see what's going because I
like the first one the first one was a
lot of fun
um let's see so there's another movie
called death trap which actually
probably been a good movie well okay I
think the tourist trap yeah tourist
traps death trap was also known as eaten
alive
um which the thing about it though was
that there was another movie called
death trap that was I think like a
murder mystery like a funny comedy
murder mystery and I think there was
like some hijinks around that where
people like got it confused with this
movie I think that happened a lot you
know what I'm saying like because stuff
would get caught in the net because like
I mentioned earlier about like The Best
Little Whorehouse in Texas where they
just came in and saw the title and
presumed oh that must be a porno movie
even though it's not it's like a musical
comedy there's like not even an e any
boobs in it as far as I remember because
we reviewed it not too long ago
let's see uh Deep River Savages or man
from Deep River I know it is man from
Deep River delirium don't go in the
house don't go into the park don't look
in the basement don't do all these
things uh Evil Dead there's another one
uh so evil dead is another one that's uh
a really good movie that's on the list
Frozen scream I kind of remember that
one the fun house uh I guess that's the
Toby number one that's great that's
actually a good movie okay so that's
three I can recommend that's a good one
I can recommend evil speak
dead and buried and fun house and the
fun house fun house and the evil dead
yeah but yeah he's probably seen that
everybody's seen labels yeah I feel like
the fun house was good
I really yeah there was something about
the fun house that I really like yeah
something 81 maybe 1980 around that time
the fun house was yeah I can't remember
but like I said that's the Toby Hooper
movie yeah
uh human experiments here's the funny
one uh there's a movie called I miss you
hugs and kisses
and this movie was not as far as I
remember this was not a horror movie it
ended up on the list because one person
somewhere complained about it because I
guess they were expecting a different
kind of movie and it turned out like but
it really has like other than a couple
very very minor scenes of violence it
has nothing in it that would warrant its
place on the list and for all of these
years people have been mystified as to
what it was exactly that warranted this
movie big on the video Nazis list even
though it's only like in the second tier
or whatever but I haven't seen it but
I've heard that it's like it's not even
a horror movie or anything like some of
these aren't some of them are like I
said some of her like Nazi exploitation
or some of them are
um because I kind of feel like a lot of
the older ones were it wasn't even just
so much horror like you know rape or
evisceration or things like that they
were offended by sometimes in the early
days they'd be offended by
um just to kind of like General
anti-authority kind of attitude or
something like that like one documentary
that I was watching about that wasn't
necessarily about video nasties but it
was about like the British border film
classifications like just Through the
Ages and they were talking about letters
they had received about movies as far
back as like you know Marlon Brando like
in the wild one and stuff like that and
people like writing and complaining
about that like you know oh this listen
to the way he's talking to like an adult
and things like that they would get like
really offended I'm like oh my God
people were such like [ __ ] snowflakes
back then
um but yeah so there was that uh also
Inferno which I'm assuming is the Dario
Argento one again yeah it's violent but
I mean that's a great [ __ ] movie not
as good as Suspiria obviously but uh
still a great killer none uh late night
trains Living Dead in the Manchester
morgue that was all right I haven't seen
in a long time uh nightmare maker
possession that's what uh Zach was just
talking about like I said as far as I
know pretty much the only art film that
turned up on there
pranks a prisoner of the cannibal God
revenge of the boogeyman the Slayer
terrorized also known as night school
the toolbox Murders uh I remember seeing
that when we rented that one a bunch of
times unhinged visiting hours I remember
visiting hours being okay that was the
one in the hospital right like that was
at the hospital I remember that one
being all right
um the witch who came from the sea I
watched that fairly recently and I
cannot imagine like why that would have
offended anyone but you know what I mean
it's it's this many years later it's
kind of hard to like
cast our eyes back and like figure out
women Behind Bars yeah there was a lot
of these women in prison movies that
they didn't like those either uh zombie
creeping flesh also known as hell of the
Living Dead I remember that one I don't
think that one was all that memorable I
did see it but
uh the section three ones these were
this was like um a supplementary list
and this was like
not the official list but the the movies
on this list you couldn't prosecute
these for obscenity but they still I
guess left it open that you could seize
these
um if you if in your discretion that you
thought that these were less obscene but
still not really appropriate for anyone
to rent
um also these could be destroyed
after they were forfeited so you had
some of those I'm trying to think of
like some of these blue eyes of the
broken doll I think that's a giallo film
I think I'm going to get around to doing
that one of these days more cannibal
movies Christmas evil uh I think we
talked about that maybe last Christmas
or the Christmas before that's kind of
like a terrible movie Alice Sweet Alice
oh yeah yeah for Christ's sake that's a
great [ __ ] I can recommend that too
um they have it listed as communion
which that's what it might be called in
the UK I'm not really sure I know that's
the alternate title but over here it's
known as Alice Sweet Alice and that's a
[ __ ] fantastic movie that's like an
American yellow it's like a gyllo movie
but Luciano slasher hybrid but like with
a
I was gonna say with a kid killer but
not necessarily you know what I mean
that's kind of like what they're trying
to make you think that uh brutes and
Savages cannibal cannibal world
uh Dawn of the Dead
come on Dawn of the Dead
that's also a great movie Dawn of the
Mummy dead kids aka strange Behavior I
saw that recently and there's really not
much to that either deep red profondo
Rosso I
that's a great [ __ ] movie two
um demented the demons
don't answer the phone
there's more of those don't movies
donates the phone don't go in the
basement don't watch this movie eaten
alive that's the Toby Hooper run that's
the one that I'm thinking of enter the
devil uh the erotic rights of
Frankenstein
that's funny now I kind of want to see
that just from the title The Evil
uh the evil that was the one you like
that move that's that one like yeah yeah
yeah is that the same one that we're
talking about yeah that's a good movie
that's a really good that's a real good
movie uh it was just 1978 I think yeah
low budget California movie uh taking
place in a big old [ __ ] like
abandoned um
Pro it's probably a hotel
and uh it's kind of like uh
oh [ __ ]
kind of like the Legend of Hell House
it's similar to that it's a good play
the evil it is good I like it a lot it's
like a ghost story right
uh let's see the Executioner final exam
Foxy Brown
why Foxy Brown I don't know that's not
even a horror movie that a Pam Grier and
it's black exploitation
that's just like a fun
yeah it says past and edited form for
Cinema passed with two minutes and 48
seconds of cuts in 1987.
other released uncut in 1998 what the
what could they possibly have cut out of
that I haven't seen in a long time but I
don't remember anything particularly
offensive uh Friday the 13th
which I don't even remember anything
in that that was particularly egregious
like I said I mean I'm probably not the
best judge because I'm just kind of like
yeah whatever machete in the face all
right
I've seen way worse Friday 13th part two
um let's see gbh graduation day happy
birthday to me I remember that one that
was the one with like the chick from uh
Little House on the Prairie the the girl
that played Mary and I remember like
somebody got skewered that's really the
only thing I remember that movie is like
somebody getting skewered through the
[ __ ] mouth with a
like a shish kebab thing I remember that
uh hell prison The Hills Have Eyes
that's another Wes Craven one part of
West Craven
another great movie honestly at home
honeymoon horror and seminoid
that's another one that I've been
wanting to do like on the show because
that's it that's on 2B invasion of the
blood Farmers uh killing hour last
horror film The Last Hunter the love
butcher
mad Fox's Mark of the devil Mark of the
devil's great if you never I used to
have a t-shirt
um that had like a newspaper ad that was
like complaining about Mark of the devil
the the only thing I remember from that
I remember it being good it's kind of
like a witch Panic like uh so it has
like a lot of torture and [ __ ] in it the
main thing that I remember from it is
somebody when it's somebody getting like
a [ __ ] nail drove through their
tongue or something like that it was
pretty [ __ ] up you know what I mean so
I'm surprised it didn't turn up like
higher up on the list Martin
the George or Marathon it's hard to
believe that's on that list why is that
on there oh
I don't know uh Massacre Mansion
Mausoleum I saw Mausoleum like a year
ago and I just remember it being kind of
boring yeah no it didn't impress me I
rented it once a long time ago I was
like that yeah it's on I think it's on
shutter or it's on something I just
watched it I don't remember anything
about it yeah I don't remember it it
wasn't that great it wasn't
there like I said a lot of these movies
probably like they get a lot more
attention just because they were on this
list like if they hadn't been put on
this list and somebody like crying about
them like nobody would even remember
them probably uh naked fist the nesting
that's another one that I keep see
coming up because it's on 2B I think and
it's like is that the one about the
roaches or am I thinking of the nest
because I know there was a okay the
nesting I don't remember that one then
The New Adventures of Snow White uh AKA
Grim fairy tales for adults which okay
that sounds dirty night Beast Night of
the Living Dead for Christ's sake which
dumb why okay
um although that says password cuts for
Cinema release uncut in 1987. downgraded
to a 15 certificate in 2007 so they
finally like [ __ ] realized seriously
it's not that bad uh nightmare City AKA
City The Walking Dead Oasis of the
zombies uh parasite Phantasm that's
another movie that's uh that's [ __ ]
great
the original Phantasm although they it
does say that um it was passed uncut for
Cinema like when it played in the
theaters and then was passed uncut for
video in 1918 and then was downgraded to
a 15 certificate in 2005. so even back
then they knew that that wasn't all that
bad that movie is like so [ __ ] weird
I don't really know
why they would have uh pigs pray prom
night rabid oh there's David Cronenberg
although that was passed on cut for
Cinema also passed on cup for video 1992
Rosemary's killer Savage Terror scanners
scream for vengeance Shogun Assassin oh
good movie that is a good Shogun
Assassin is a Lone Wolf and Cub all
three movies [ __ ] crunched into about
[ __ ] an hour hour and a half
it's still kind of fun and watchable
but it's Shogun it's uh it's Lone Wolf
and Cub I got the crisis seriously see
all the Lone Wolf uncut movies though
because they're awesome yeah that's
where the Mandalorian came from there's
like six of them right uh I think there
might be six now I think I thought there
was three maybe there's more I got them
all that's a big like Criterion
Collection yeah it's a beautiful package
between three and five maybe
um there might be six
but that's that's where
um the man that's where the Mandalorian
came from about a Samurai and a baby
with a cart
one of the moves is called Baby cart to
hell yeah yeah all kinds of weird [ __ ]
her baby cart to Hades or whatever it
was yeah
yeah
those are yeah I like those I like those
movies yeah he he was like he was like
the shogun's head assassin head [ __ ]
executioner and uh the show can turn
against him and called for his death and
the death of his child they went on the
Run
you know so they were Outlaws and it's
called Lone Wolf and Cub and it's it
it's where they got the idea for the
Mandalorian yeah it's essentially the
men of the Proto Mandalore yeah his
little son's with him in his little
kimono with his head shaved in his
little top knot his name is
cute that kid is adorable that's where
they got baby Yoda from yeah that kid's
adorable and he and he's a badass yeah
he kills people with the baby car yeah
his favorite cards got blades in it yeah
it's got like all kind of like booby
traps and [ __ ] like it could shoot like
Spears yeah it's awesome yeah they're
walking that's awesome they're walking
the path to hell yeah is what what
they're calling they're going out in a
blaze of glory all those movies are good
yeah I gotta watch those again all those
movies are good we had yeah like I said
we have the Criterion Collection if you
can afford it like yeah yeah she got it
for me as a gift yeah it looks like
parchment paper
drawings and [ __ ] it like all folds out
I think it's six movies yeah
Mrs Evans already party said I rented
the foreign film high tension that's a
French film if you don't know in 2006
expecting a normal American Slasher
it was very graphic yeah uh they do
stuff differently over the pond from us
um yeah high tension was part of the
what they call the new French extremity
which uh you know it's kind of Gone by
the wayside now but yeah there was a
time in the mid to late 2000s when
France was kind of like on The Cutting
Edge of like way [ __ ] up [ __ ] so we
were doing some [ __ ] up [ __ ] in our
horror movies over there but if you
wanted to see some really [ __ ] up [ __ ]
then you would see a French movie
because man they were doing some
terrible terrible things over there high
tension is a great movie though a lot I
know that the ending is kind of uh
controversial
but because a lot of people didn't like
it or thought it was dumb or whatever
but I didn't mind it I didn't mind it
uh she also asked those faces of death
even real some of it was most of it was
not most of it was fake got several
people in there talking about how they
love Shogun Assassin and they're talking
about certain scenes so if you like
Shogun Assassin
go ahead and [ __ ] get rent the whole
Lone Wolf and Cub series if if you can
stream it if not just buy the Criterion
Edition I think it's like close to 100
bucks though it might even be more I
think it was a limited production it's
probably worth several hundred you could
probably you could probably get it
non-criteria no Edition maybe I would
imagine wolfen cup yeah the the series
is far more
um intelligible and rational than
a chauvinist acid shotgun assassins
[ __ ] just
crazy it's crazy it's a fun movie but
that's not really the story
well I think that's kind of like the
thing that happened a lot I mean it
started happening I think like even in
the 70s where people were like oh
everybody likes those kung fu movies so
we're gonna like get these really cheap
like [ __ ] movies from over like you
know Kung Fu movies from over there and
we're just gonna or even or series and
then they would cut them all together
like into one of this like 90 minute two
hour movie that made absolutely no sense
at all because they were just like
cutting together all the coolest scenes
yeah and it's like who the [ __ ] are
these people it's like different
characters like kicking the ass of this
person and it's just kind of yeah Shogun
Assassin isn't incoherent yeah it's fun
but that's because it was just chopped
just like the best bits from like six
movies it's not even the best bits it's
good stuff there's a lot of cool [ __ ]
that happens in all those movies but the
story is really where it's at
from The Lone wolfen cup story
it's kind of like zotuichi
if you know yeah it's like that now
zatoichi there was there's what 26 of
those 30 40. I think there's 26 uh
movies yeah it's a [ __ ] ton the blind
he's he's like a blind guy he's like the
blind swordsman yeah he's a Yakuza
swords master
but he's uh
his cover is to be a masseur
yeah it's easy so he goes around doing
massages yeah and he also like gambles
everywhere yeah he gambles and he's not
a samurai he hates Samurai he kills a
bunch of them because they're bad you
know and they're just like a bunch of
crooks
he just hangs out in brothels and
gambling houses and uh tries to save
girls from prostitution because a lot of
them are just forced in there out of
their will and he does heroic [ __ ]
so he's a Yakuza but he's a good guy
and uh
he was played by a famous Japanese actor
his name was uh katsushin or shintaro
Katsu and he can sing and there's a
bunch of videos on YouTube of him
singing
it's songs from uh from zatoichi one of
them is called darklet darkness is my
Ally but by shintaro katsu if I can
listen to that that's a [ __ ] good
it's all in Japanese
and he's just this [ __ ]
little badass dude he's not big he's
little he's kind of hunched over
not real healthy he's got all kinds of
[ __ ] VD and [ __ ] kind of turns out
later on later on in the movies he's all
diseased and [ __ ]
but it's kind of like a tragic hero it's
a good flick
oh they're all good flicks they're kind
of repetitive though
yeah I mean it's kind of like the same
story yeah the same thing so it happens
over and over you can just jump in
anywhere and watch any you don't have to
watch them in order yeah they just jump
in and watch it yeah and you can play
them in any pretty much any order there
are certain eras where certain things
happen like it turns out he has a
brother that he's been missing and the
brother is a badass too and they [ __ ]
had a fallen out over the same woman and
he killed the girl Southeast brother
killed the girls she's got to get event
Revenge
so yeah there's a bunch of cool [ __ ]
that happens in it
it's where Star Wars came from
yeah Ben says all the blades come out of
the pram it's hilarious yeah yeah talk
about you know yeah
uh the Wallace 6969 benches Mondo Connie
yeah I remember that one uh man bites
dog that's a good one too that's also
that's a French film too right that
black and white one uh yeah that was
also good mango said if you want to see
how crazy the bbfc is look at the
ratings for two films that came out the
same Year Wes Craven's New Nightmare 15
certificate and Dolores Claiborne 18
certificate does not make sense
yeah I don't get that I mean it's been a
while since I've seen either one of
those movies but not that long I mean I
don't really re I don't know why
New Nightmare I remember that being
pretty good like Dolores Claiborne
what would make that just be 18 I don't
really understand
okay I don't understand
oh yeah you guys know this it [ __ ]
pass talked about Ichi the killer that's
a good movie yeah we need to cover that
yeah I've been wanting to do that one
for a while too I can't believe like and
then um
uh legendary Diablo 7 knows that Rucker
Howard movie Blind Fury was inspired by
zatoichi the blind swordsman yes yeah I
remember them buying Fury this is okay
movie
they've done I barely remember yeah
they've done zatoichi reboots more
recently too like in the 2000s they had
new ones that came out versus out doing
she's blonde with blue eyes is [ __ ]
ridiculous you want to go back to
[ __ ] shintaro concert
accidentally killed a dude on set making
those movies whoops [ __ ] killed him
with a real sword
well bound to happen it had a problem
I guess they did and they uh yeah
[ __ ] killed dude it was a friend of
his evidently now here's the thing that
would suck shintaro katsu
shintaro katsu from um from zatoichi
it's his brother that plays the Shogun
Assassin from uh from um
from uh uh Lone Wolf and cup that's
that's that's concertin's brother
he's kind of a bigger dude and uh he's
good too
but uh
that's where uh
Star Wars came from
Star Wars the original old Star Wars
series you know Came In Like A New Hope
and everything it was supposed to be a
western
and a Samurai movie combined
if you look at the
the uh
the [ __ ] uh the Jedi the Jedi were
[ __ ] Samurai
basically and then you know Han Solo's a
[ __ ]
he's [ __ ] a wild west character
now uh
there was something else I was going to
say about that
but uh now they're [ __ ] great movies
oh I remember what it was there's a real
good Western Samurai movie
uh came out in the 70s
and it had a famous Japanese [ __ ] uh
uh actor I forgot his name mafuri
something or other he was the guy from
Tora Tora Tora and then it had Charles
Bronson and it was called Red Sun and
that's one of my favorite western movies
it's about a diplomatic train that gets
[ __ ] robbed out in like around New
Mexico
and uh the emperor of Japan was going to
give a ceremonial sword to the president
of the United States and they were going
to start opening up this diplomatic
dialogue
and some uh Train Robbers stole that
sword
and uh the dip The Diplomatic the main
Diplomat sends out this summer I got to
go retrieve that sword
and he links up with one of the one of
the Train Robbers who is uh uh [ __ ]
Charles Bronson and those two worked
their enemies and then they start
becoming friends and they work together
to try to get that [ __ ] sword back
it's called Red Sun and it's kind of
hard to find you can I don't even think
they have a Blu-ray release for it and
you may not be able to stream it but
they had it free on YouTube for a while
that's a good one that's a real good one
I really recommend that one if you're
into all this
[ __ ]
Lone Wolf [ __ ] see Red Sun real good
all right Glenn uh Ben says was there
child molesting Shannon Dolores
Claiborne maybe that's what it was
because I didn't remember that but now
that you mention it yeah maybe that's
what it was I don't think they showed
child molesting but I think they implied
it very strongly so maybe that's what it
was maybe that's what bothered them uh
the Wallace 6969 Says Megan is missing
um that's a movie I've seen it
and I actually did
um kind of like a long write up a long
time ago which I might eventually I
might like repost her on my new site but
I kind of feel like that's one of those
movies the end of it is shocking I will
give it that but I kind of feel like
it's one of those movies that it's
reputation like outstrips like what it
actually is because I kind of feel like
it really it's found footage it's
essentially but I think that it's not
the first part of it is not realistic
enough to like make me get really that
much into it I re honestly if we're
talking found footage I think the
Poughkeepsie tapes was better but Megan
is missing I think like the end of it
was good like some of the imagery like
at the end was shocking but overall I
didn't really like it all that much and
I didn't think it was as shocking as
um as it's purported to be that's all
yeah 007 I think you got it right that
was his I think his name was Tashira
mofuni I think that's who it is yeah got
from uh Tora Tora Tora he's a very
famous actor him and and uh Charles
Bronson Red's son as an s-u-n uh it was
free on YouTube man it's great flick
great flick Epic
yeah Ben says even mentioning incest or
child abuse can get at a higher rating
than a team slasher film yeah okay
I mean I don't I don't know I don't
agree with that but I guess I see where
they're coming from
but yeah so some of the other movies
that like I said these weren't
prosecuted but they were like words that
were like an adjunct Suspiria is on
there which
okay whatever
um Texas Chainsaw Massacre which like I
said if you watch that nowadays it shows
nothing
um most of the [ __ ] is like imagination
and the thing although this says past
uncut for Cinema they didn't cut
anything out when they showed in the
movies also passed uncut for video in
1987. so I don't know why they put it on
the list because they didn't take
anything out of that even though that
movie's like pretty
compared to Texas Chainsaw Massacre if I
just say like which one of those is Gory
or more [ __ ] up the thing is like way
more [ __ ] up than that it doesn't show
any it doesn't show doesn't show very
much human blood that's true mostly
alien stuff maybe that's why well and I
think that there's I don't remember who
said this but I remember somebody saying
it's like you can show as much like Gore
and [ __ ] like that as you want as long
as it's not like doesn't look like real
blood as long as it's like green yeah it
was green it was green or if it looks
like it's not human yeah you know what I
mean the thing was like that there's a
lot of green alien blood and dog parts
and stuff crap maybe that's what it was
yeah but that's but see that's why I
think that this whole like [ __ ] the
concept behind it is just like pointless
because I mean at least at least I will
give them the benefit of the doubt and
say at least they did seem to like watch
these movies like and and assess them on
their individual merits but it still
seems very very arbitrary to me you know
it just seems very arbitrary so the
thing uh Tomb of the Living Dead uh was
on there uh which we need to cover that
one of these days because somebody sent
me all those movies
werewolf woman extro uh past uncut for
Cinema also passed on cut for video in
1987 even though that has a scene of a
grown man crawling out of a woman's
vagina
so you know do you remember that no no
yeah do you remember that I remember
yeah that is a weird ass movie that is a
weird-ass movie yeah
um
and if you I think I talked about this
because I talked about on my scare Salon
but you know for a while back in the day
you know you'd see those videos where
it's like ooh Real Paranormal [ __ ] like
a real weird [ __ ] like caught on tape
you know the scene where the weird alien
with like the backwards legs and stuff
like runs across the road like I saw
that on a couple of tapes like they were
purporting to that to be like an actual
sighting because I guess they figured
that movie was too obscure and like
nobody would know that that was from a
movie form person I think but it's from
isn't it a movie it's from extra there
is a deformity where people come out
that shape either that it's a guy on its
back but I've seen a video of a guy that
looked even worse than that in Brazil
just
walking on all fours
oh I kind of feel like that was probably
just somebody on their back going like
that either that or it was just like a
creature that they built I'm not really
sure it's been a long time since I've
seen it so I'm not really sure if like
but yeah um and then there were as a
couple that were films banned by the
bbfc but not classes video nasties which
would include Maniac probably because of
that scalping scene uh Mother's Day New
York Ripper which I just can't uh salute
you fochie I just like talked about that
and that's a long ago Silent Night
deadly night which isn't really that
that's not that gory I think it was just
everyone got offended people got
offended in this country too because
they were just like Santa Claus can't
kill people you know oh and Straw Dogs
Straw Dogs is a great [ __ ] that's Sam
pekapo it's a great [ __ ] movie I
think everybody got offended by that
movie which in a way I can see why
the thing that offended everybody about
that movie it's again kind of like a
rape Revenge film
is that the rape scene
um the woman seems like she's getting
raped and then like after a time she
looks like she's starting to like get
into it or she's like enjoying it and I
think a lot of people had a problem with
that
which I get it I get that uh but I think
that's kind of the issue that they had
with Straw Dogs
more than anything else it's violent but
it's not like not more violent than
anything else I've ever seen
um and then there were other films
seized by the police but not classed as
video nasty's Basket Case uh which
that's ridiculous because that's like a
silly ass movie Blood for Dracula uh
which I think was the Andy warholm one
city the living dead that's another
Lucio Fouche one which actually has a
scene where a woman barfs up Urban
intestines and has somebody like have a
drill through their head so I don't know
why that wouldn't be on the scene
Macabre madman Knight of the seagulls
which I haven't seen Terror Express
other films like I said A Clockwork
Orange we talked about that earlier
which well that was not banned by the
government they actually passed it
um uh Stanley Kubrick was the one that
withdrew that okay because he got death
threats all right what ended up
happening I think was that
the film I think they actually passed it
like it was okay to show in cinemas
um but later on like Stanley Cooper kept
getting death threats because of all the
[ __ ] in it so he decided that he wasn't
he was gonna pull it ridiculous yeah so
so they didn't show it there uh Child's
Play Three which I mentioned earlier
that was because of the James Bulger
murder they thought that it had
something to do with like the kids
killing that little boy uh so they kind
of like uh they didn't bang it well they
don't know if they banned it necessarily
but they kind of like kind of freak out
about that
um The Exorcist this was actually never
officially cut or never officially
banned in the UK I mean The Exorcist the
[ __ ] classic right but what ended up
happening it played fine uncut in the in
the theaters but then when it started to
like come out on video uh James Furman
who I think mango mentioned earlier who
was a bbfc sensor at the time he's
basically like he tried to get Cuts made
or he tried to get it censored because
he's like oh like the pizzazz girl in
the movie she's too young you know she's
12 years old
um and this so you know kids that are
underage might be coming to see this and
also I guess and this is probably like
part of the marketing hype but they said
oh there were all these like you know uh
people like young people that were
coming to see the movie that were having
like all these hysterical reactions and
[ __ ] like that
so um so that might be like contributing
so I don't know basically it's just kind
of like it was theatrically re-released
in 1998 which I remember because I went
and re-saw it like in the theater when
it came out because they'd added more
stuff to it and then after that like
Furman retired uh from the censorship
board in 1999 so it got resubmitted like
for home video release and they passed
it uncut it just had an 18 certificate
which like I said it's like that's
equivalent to like an R rating which you
know fine
um that's fine last house on Dead End
Street scum oh I remember that one I
remember that movie that's not even a
horror movie but yeah okay I remember
that and uh the movie Mikey this was
actually withdrawn from I remember this
not being that bad but they actually
withdrew it because of the James Bulger
murder because they thought there were
too many similarities and they thought
that like somebody like I said I think
they were kind of more concerned about
like particularly stuff that turned up
in movies that had to do with kids and
they were afraid that like a kid might
see this and
you know emulate it I think was their
main concern
um and barring that I think nowadays
really their main concerns or like I
said real life animal cruelty they still
cut that which like I said I don't
really have a problem with that
um and they said if it's real like
egregious like violence toward women
like super like horrible rape or
something like that like they'll kind of
look a scant at that but other than that
most things as far as I'm aware like
we'll pass nowadays without them really
like being all that concerned about it
but those are really like the only two
things that they still are kind of like
hey maybe not you know what I mean uh
Ben says scum the rape scene is
notorious yeah that's right I forgot
it's been a long time since I've seen
scum but I did remember there was like a
rape scene in there and I will say that
like rape scenes in movies they do
bother me I don't think you should like
cut them though like I just recently saw
what was that [ __ ] movie um
irreversible
um that has like a really
it's not that graphic but just like how
long it goes on and like how [ __ ]
seedy and gross and [ __ ] it is it's like
it's really really hard to watch
so but I wouldn't argue that you should
cut it though I mean that [ __ ] really
happens in real life it's like probably
so I so I don't really have an argument
with like showing it in a movie as long
as I don't like showing it to kids and
stuff
Pat says maybe it also has to do with
the quality of the blood the thing had
very dark blood maybe that's it or maybe
not
mango said they never reviewed New York
Ripper they sent it straight back again
they had it in for folgy I could see
that I could see that Ben says City the
Living Dead some people snuck into our
Film Society screening just when the guy
gets impaled on the drill then left in
shock I don't understand how people can
find that entertaining well there's your
problem the city of the Living Dead is a
fun it's a great movie I mean it's a fun
movie like I said you get to watch a
girl barf up her own intestines it's
it's a good time and uh the fact that
you have people regulating
movies where they don't understand why
anybody would want to watch them is part
of the problem
it's like I don't watch that because
it's like ooh look it's like I'm glad
that person's dead or whatever it's just
kind of like I don't know I can't
explain it to somebody that's not I
don't understand horrible they don't
understand horror movies they don't
understand like the whole history behind
it it's like they don't have any context
they don't know the fandom right we're
not watching it because we're depraved
horrible [ __ ] it's like it's
not it's not like that you know what I
mean it's hard to explain to somebody
who's just not into it mostly just
analyzing The Craft
that's what I'm saying it's like if you
can show me something that looks so
[ __ ] real that I'm fooled or like you
know just the way you portray it as like
artistic or something like that that's
its own art form and I don't think they
understand that I like some horror
movies I like I like you know I can
differentiate between good ones and bad
ones
it's not really my thing though really
to be honest you know which I'm always
honest about it
um I like more
sci-fi and fantasy and uh
epic [ __ ] epic action movies sometimes
it depends on what it is military stuff
I like that Horrors I can't take 24
horror 24 7. she can she can just yeah I
love singing watching things over and
over I love that I'm like this I'm like
a sometimes [ __ ] when it comes
to horror
some of it's good and some of it's not
good
a lot of it's just boring that's why you
know but the thing is is like
action movies a lot of them are boring
yeah I find a lot of them yeah a lot
they're very samey it depends yeah it
depends on it depends on what it is
because I like I like a lot of horror I
like a lot of action movies too yeah I
like some sci-fi but mostly like I said
I'm I'm a horror movie person but I like
lots of different kinds of genres and uh
if something's good I'll watch it I
don't care what genre and I like a
mixture of sci-fi and horror too you
know
I like that also
but yeah he's like like I'll watch
horror in True Crime happily like 24 7.
it doesn't bother me in this latest True
Crime gets to me if I watch that [ __ ]
too much it gets too damn depressing for
me it feels like a reality well it is
reality yeah yeah it's not a reality I
want to focus on you know I don't
understand like why it's I'm not saying
it doesn't I can take it in limited
batches but it becomes too much then you
know if you stare into the abyss too
long you become the abyss that kind of
thing I don't like that [ __ ] yeah but
it's like I don't know like I'm not
saying it doesn't bother me because it
does you know and you know because like
I said I write books about this [ __ ] so
it's like a lot of times like I'm
immersed in like real [ __ ] that happens
you know and I'm just like reading these
horrible details all the time it bothers
me I'm not saying it doesn't bother me
but it's like not so much that I'm gonna
stop doing it
and I don't know why that is I can't
explain it bothers me to the point to
where if you if you start watching that
too much you think it's common so you
think it's going to happen to you and
people that you know no I'm not there It
Is Well I understand that right so it's
it doesn't get to me I I guess maybe
from an anti-personnel background in the
military and [ __ ] we're killing people
was [ __ ] lauded that's what you were
supposed to do you know if you weren't
just killing the enemy if you didn't
enjoy it if you didn't then so when I
see all this [ __ ] I'm like man there's a
dude like me who's on the other side
who's out there you know I mean so it's
it's a different reality for me uh I
think for her it's something she's
watching she knows that it happens but
it's something that I might have to
prevent or do so it's well the thing
about it though is that I'm coming at it
too from the point of view of like work
to me
well I mean it's like that to me too but
in some ways it's like well and coming
at it too like as a woman it's probably
like more likely that some [ __ ] like
that is gonna would happen to me but at
least but I have enough distance on it
to know it's like well this could happen
because you know it happened to like
other people like me but it's like it
probably won't like I shouldn't worry
about it because it's like yeah it could
happen and that would be bad but you
know you can't go through your life
worrying about that happening to you but
my boy granter's in there he's an ex-cop
so he know he knows [ __ ] the reality
of that kind of [ __ ] and seeing that and
living immersed in that for too long can
take you over uh so it's especially
and I've held a [ __ ] beautiful girl's
head in my hands I'm just crushed you
know
drug her body down the [ __ ] center of
a dam bus [ __ ] with a surrounded by
dead bodies during a [ __ ] crash
rescue that me and my unit did down in
uh right outside charmel Sheik and
[ __ ] Egypt because we were the First
Responders to that [ __ ]
and it's just dead bodies are something
that were a reality to me you know
it gets to when you start reading about
dudes like [ __ ] Raider and these
other guys you're like you're making
more of those you know what I mean why
are you doing that it's just a different
to me it has a different impact so I
can't be immersed in it all the time you
know but I think in some ways and like I
said maybe this is something that people
that aren't into horror like don't
realize like I said in a way it kind of
I don't know I I think it's in most
people I think it kind of makes them
like more empathetic in a weird way
is that is that a weird thing to say I I
kind of feel like that it does but
and reading about True Crime too because
you're constantly reading about all this
horrible [ __ ] that happens to these poor
people that did nothing to deserve it
and the more that you read about serial
killers and [ __ ] like that I'm I don't
find myself like relating more to the
serial killers I find myself relating
more to the victims and being like what
the [ __ ] is the matter with these
[ __ ] people you know what I mean but
it's like but it's interesting because
it's like look what can go wrong yeah to
me it's too depressing to be in it all
the time though yeah that's that's all
yeah I get that it's like I don't know
it it doesn't because it's not it's
actually not a normal phase of life it's
not you know what I mean to wallow in it
you'll eventually normalize it or accept
it
because I just I you know just nah
it's good
Ben says the thing that freaked me out
most in city of the Living Dead was when
he opened the coffin with the pickaxe
see that scene I was like bro you know
she's alive in there she's screaming why
on Earth would you take the pickaxe like
right where you know her face is like
she's telling you help me let me out of
this coffin I got buried alive and then
he just like immediately like goes here
her face is probably like right here
chunk and then he's like okay it's like
right there you know what I mean I was
like dude that was like the stupidest
thing ever
uh Ian England says I find anything I
become immersed in basically makes me
numb to it I don't know that I've become
I don't know that I'm numb to it though
I don't know it's like it's really like
I said it's kind of hard for me to
explain because like I read about these
[ __ ] even nowadays like as old and as
jaded as I am like I'll still read about
a case every now and I go but [ __ ] I'm
like that is [ __ ] up you know what I
mean because I because I think about it
but it's like I don't think
I don't know I don't think it maybe it
does that for some people but I don't
think that I've ever like become like
completely numb to it
like in a lot of ways you get numb to
like horror movies but like I said
that's fake you know what I mean the you
know and you know that's fake so it's
just kind of like
you know so you can watch [ __ ] up [ __ ]
on there and be like yeah it's [ __ ] up
but it's not real yeah it's not I
I just don't I just really can't take
True Crime over and over again watching
that [ __ ] seeing the photographs of the
people and everything just I can do it
in in limited
stretches you know
but uh no she can go on that [ __ ]
because that's her job you know she
likes writing those books but I I can't
do it yeah hell when you were not
remember when you went to Mississippi to
see your dad yeah like in the evenings
like if I couldn't think of anything
else to watch I just put on like cold
case files yeah and I would just like
watch that for hours and hours
I had to sit there and watch cold case
files for hours yeah I get depressed I
watched like all those two crashes
you're watching yeah looking over my
shoulder and [ __ ] and [ __ ] worried
about people creeping in through [ __ ]
windows and [ __ ] that kind of stuff
you know but look if you want to eat
tonight I have to get off the show and
start cooking holy [ __ ] it's almost 10
o'clock yeah yeah and you're and we've
been on for probably four hours almost
okay almost four hours
I gotta make us something to eat because
she's probably gonna watch movies though
but I'll see you guys uh what not not
tomorrow the next day though right yeah
Friday night Friday night yeah yeah and
I gotta remember like I have to find a
high school photo of me from somewhere
you guys are gonna laugh when you
[ __ ] see it but yeah thanks for
dropping by this evening I know this one
was kind of like all over the map but
you know whatever we were talking about
censorship and horror movies and stuff
like that so we were just kind of like
all over the place so you know hopefully
that was that was all right like I said
I got really busy today and I was like
really really I watched a couple
documentaries and I like read a bunch of
like articles and stuff that I'm like
I'm not ready I was like so behind but
you know what I mean okay so hopefully
everybody had a really good time uh have
a good rest of your evening you guys and
have a good day tomorrow we're going to
take the day off tomorrow as we usually
do on Thursdays but we'll be back on
Friday night for our Sidetrack show
where we'll just be like talking about
whatever so hopefully you guys can drop
by and see us then
so we will see you guys on Friday night
thank you very much for dropping by and
thank you for your super chats and we'll
see you then bye